over the last 13 years I've personally
closed 4,000 sales and these are the six
elements of The Ultimate Sales blueprint
so let's begin with sales multipliers
these things right off the bat will make
you more money first sales multiplier
sell 7even
days per week now the reason this is so
important is that a lot of business
owners want to make more money in their
business a lot of sales people want to
close more sales but they only choose to
close days a week but the interesting
thing is that and depending on the
industry sometimes the off hours from
like 5:00 p.m. onwards is when the most
of your prospects are available so like
in Fitness where I came from I closed
all my sales from 4: until 8:00 p.m. and
so if you're like well I only want to
work between 9 to 5: it's like well
guess what no one's going to buy during
that time and so you can probably close
more sales in the back at the day uh and
on Saturdays and Sundays than you would
during the normal 9 to5 so is especially
true in like retail and businesses where
you sell to Consumers who work normal
jobs and you have to sell basically on
the times that they're available so sell
during the weekends the other piece of
selling seven days a week is like
there's actual math behind this and so
there's 52 weeks a year and so if you
have 52 weeks per year times two days
right is 104 days of sales extra per
year which is 29% increase over just
selling 5 days a week and so if you want
to immediately increase your sales by
29% sell on weekends and I know I've
tried to sell you on this but I'm going
to give you one more really good reason
to sell over the weekend if you've ever
tried to book sales and skip the
weekends so you've got Friday here and
then you've got Saturday and then Sunday
and then Monday right and so you skip
these days and so then this Monday gets
stacked right you have all these people
who are saying like oh man um I'm going
to show up so your sales guys get
they're like oh dude Monday looks big
but as soon as Monday happens it's no
show no show no show no show reschedule
and you're like what the hell well you
didn't make it available at the time
when they wanted to actually come which
is Saturday and Sunday that's when they
clicked on the ad that's when they
actually made the booking and believe it
or not from a lot of our portfolio
companies we get more people who
actually schedule on Saturdays and
Sundays for Monday which means that they
are available right then to buy cuz
they've got time and so when you do it
this way not only do you sell two more
days per week which is 104 days more per
year which is 29% increase in Revenue
that assumes just a flat increase but if
you pull up the appointments from Monday
to Saturday when they scheduled and
Sunday when they scheduled you then get
same day next day showup rates which
your showup rates also go up on those
days so not only do you schedule more
people because it only works for sat
them on Saturday and Sunday and they
didn't want to do Monday you also get
higher show up rates on Saturday and
Sunday for the people who wanted to
schedule then because that was when it
was convenient for them and so you get a
multiplier effect across the entire
business of sales by simply adding two
more days in a year so it's minimum 29%
sometimes more next up respond to leads
in less than one minute now you may not
know the stats on this some of the more
experienced salespeople do if you can
contact a lead within 60 seconds of them
showing interest or opting in or giving
you their contact information you have a
391 per increase in the likelihood that
you can close the Prospect and so that
means that if you did nothing else but
simply put the processes in place so
that you can contact leads within 60
seconds you could 4X your business
tomorrow and so then you have to ask the
question what are all these other things
that I'm spending my time on and do
those things have an immediate 4X
increase in my business if the answer no
then you should probably stop doing
those things and do this one obvious
thing that can increase your business to
such a large degree also 50% of
prospects will go with the business that
response to them first not the one who's
best that they did the most research for
simply the one that responds them first
and I remember when Lila was we were out
of town we were scheduling some or she
was scheduling something for her hair or
whatever and she went to a salon and she
called them and she said hey are you
available right now to take me and
they're like no we're only appointment
only and she said cool hung up called
the next one she's like are you
available to take me now they said no
hung up next one they answered and she
and they said yes we can take you in
right now they're the ones who got the
business and here's the crazy part is
the first two owners maybe they're like
I don't know why customers aren't com
you didn't make it convenient for them
right and so the thing is is that people
have huge motivation for a tiny period
of time and when they knock on the door
in that tiny period of time you want to
open it and welcome them in and like
okay Alex but you know one minute's a
lot well totally and if you do greater
than five minutes the likelihood that
you close them drops by 80% which means
four out of five times you would have
closed now goes to 20% close rate on
those leads and so the whole idea that
people think that the lead quality is go
down is not really true it's completely
dependent on how well you work the leads
now a lot of people like to talk about
follow-up and follow- Up's important
right you got to make it personal you
got to make it fast you want to do it
multiple times over multiple days for
sure but one of the most important
follow-ups is the first followup which
is how quickly you can show them that
you have received their interest and are
ready to help them and customers will
make a judgment on how good your
business is how buttoned up you are by
how quickly you respond so if you reach
out to a company just imagine for a
second you opt into something and then
within 5 Seconds your phone rings and
someone's like hey saw that you asked
for more information about this how can
I help you right and right there you're
like man these guys are on top of it it
makes it judgment that you cast over the
entire business that first impression
it's the tip of the spear and most
people are missing out so all the data
that I will cite in this video will come
from two sources so one is there was a
Harvard Business Review uh that did a
huge case study on different sales
metrics across massive Industries and
then me personally won Allen and so a
lot of the lead nurture stats are
related to Allen which is a software
company that we own uh which is like
4,000 plus appointments per day and so
we could see how changing scheduling and
changing hours per day and things like
that affected overall throughput because
we could see from click to close and so
we could see house opening up calendars
was the single strongest correlate to
overall throughput more than increasing
closing percentages by you know 10% 20%
because you couldn't get 400% increases
in closing like you can by putting these
sales multipliers in that I'm talking
about right now these are all the things
that happen outside of the sale that
affect your sales more than anything
that happens inside the sale now the
next one in the spirit of all this speed
of response is it's good to have someone
have the option to schedule but you know
what else you can give them call now and
so when someone clicks down your funnel
and they click over to your schedule or
something if you can add a dropdown that
says call now because now they're
calling you and now the intent could not
be stronger now if you're in a business
where you're like oh man we have to
qualify leads more fine put the call out
thing after you've qualified the lead
duh right and so just think through how
we need to do this and if you're like
man I don't have the sales team to
support it think about it like this if
you can 3x your business or double your
business by simply hiring one more sales
rep if the relative increase in revenue
is significantly greater than the cost
of onboarding one more sales rep then
you should make that investment so that
you can have the coverage for your
prospects to call you to give you money
all right so let's talk about the next
one which is time slots so if you are
going to have them Book on a scheduler
then how do you set up that schedule a
lot of people don't put any time or
thought into this now we already covered
the seven days a week but what about the
actual day layout itself now most people
say okay I'm going to have these one
hour time slots 1 hour uh you know 1
hour whatever now what we found out with
Allan
is that we could increase the overall
schedule rate and show up rate by simply
changing how the times appeared on the
calendar and so we set this up so that
we would have 15 minute slots so you
might be thinking how am I going to sell
in 15 minutes you're not you allow them
to start in 15-minute increments and
then we know that the next three blocks
are used up and then somebody else books
here now some of you might say wait a
second that means that some of my sales
guys are going to have awkward times in
between well there's two solutions one
is hire more sales reps number two is
you need to have something called an
off-the call sop and so you have an
onthe call sop which is standard
operating procedure which is what do you
do when you're on the call of the
prospect but if you have a no-show or
there's off the call or you don't have
somebody on your calendar then you need
to have step- by-step of what they need
to do when they're not actually on a
call and most people only address the on
the call and don't address the off the
call which is why their sales people
aren't nearly as productive and so by
doing 15-minute time slots people pick a
time that is more convenient for them
and so I think on one level because it's
more convenient for them it's more
precisely convenient they show up at a
higher percentage I think the other
reason and there's this big
misconception about the idea of like no
I want to make it look like I'm busy and
not have full availability completely
dumb it doesn't do anything to literally
take up slots that are not true to show
that you have traffic it's dumb it just
it's dumb I just stop it we've already
looked at it it doesn't do anything it
just makes it less convenient for your
customer to book with you now in the
offthe call sop all right what should
they be doing then I'll give you the
next hack which
is you start pulling up appointments so
you remember I said we had the Monday
Sunday Saturday whatever and people are
booking on Saturday for Monday right
they're booking here because you didn't
put any availability well if you do have
your salesperson working and they have
an off-the call block where they don't
have anything on their calendar what
they should be doing is they should be
let me see if I can draw a phone here
there you go calling these leads and
then pulling them up and so when you
have that conversation with the prospect
the first thing you're doing is
qualifying them which you should do
anyways with any leads that are on the
calendar that are going to take a full
sale slot but secondarily when you call
them to qualify them say hey I had an
opening later today that just opened up
do you want the slot and so it takes a
three-day out appointment and makes it a
same day appointment and anyone who's
been in sales knows that same day
appointments have way higher SHP rates
than future appointments next is is the
actual uh person if they can't move it
up for whatever reason you still have
contacted them within just a few minutes
of them opting in so they know that
you're legit you've already qualified
them and by pulling them off and moving
them up if you do have that situation
you increase the salesperson's
utilization because now their whole
calendar has more sales appointments
that are stacked fewer Open Spaces which
is good and we now have opened up this
slot right here so that somebody else
can find it convenient and then book in
in the future and so by simply changing
what people do off the call you increase
the sales utilization you increase
booking rates and you increase show
rates by adding this one thing to what
your sales people do when they currently
weren't doing anything waiting between
calls so the next one is very
controversial and a lot of bad sales
people are going to be against it but
the killers are going to be nodding
their head so what you want to do is you
want to
feed the killers now what does that mean
is that the best leads should go to the
best closers and the worst leads should
go to the worst closers and so you're
like wait a second what do you mean my
my worst leads go to my work yeah
because that means that you have the
lowest amount of net waste within the
business the people who are the most
closable who are the most qualified who
have the most money go to the people who
have the highest likelihood of closing
them for the most money and so I'll tell
you a story when I learned this so there
was a guy who lives in my building he
does like 3 million a year in personal
income and
he was the number one sales rep or still
is the number one sales rep for a time
share company that's a multi-billion
dollar company he the number one time
share company he was the number one
sales rep and he's won the best sales
rep of the year out of 3,000 sales reps
five out of the last six years and so I
had dinner with him and I was like so
give me give me your give me your
strategy he's like you know I won the
first year when just with the existing
system but then I got to have one hour
with the CEO as kind of like the prize
for winning best salesman plus you know
a check or whatever and I was like okay
he said so when I sat down with the CEO
I closed him on basically changing the
way they allocated leads and he said so
they used to just round robin all the
leads to all the salespeople and he said
when I went to the CEO I said listen
you're just throwing money down the
toilet you're giving me people that no
one has a chance of closing and they're
completely unqualified and you're
wasting my time and then I see some
really qualified person go to a dud
closer's office and then he misses it
and it's like shoot you should give him
my terrible Le is not going to close
them anyways and give me the good one
and I'll close him and so the CEO
decided to test it just with the
location that this salesman was at he
took his income from $250,000 a year to
$3 million a year for him as a Salesman
personal income but what was more
important is that it 5x the company when
they rolled it out Nationwide he
increased the total output for that one
location by so much that they then
rolled it out and so this goes to show
that if you're like wait I feel bad
about this this is a business decision
but if you are worried about your worst
Sal people turning out why are you
worried about your worst sales to people
turning out now the other side of this
which is really nice a lot of people
don't think about is if your top sales
rep can make a million dollar a year or
$500,000 a year or $3 million a year do
you know the amount of people who will
work for nothing for the opportunity to
make that kind of money and so what
happens is salespeople will come in and
work for way below the the normal wage
for their skill because they want the
shot the opportunity to be top dog and
the other piece that this trains for or
helps the business out with is that if
someone survives this churn Factory of
down here where it's really hard for
guys to get started because they're
getting the worst leads they learn on
the hardest people to close and then
when they survive and they can still
make enough to move up then they get
better and better leads but now they
have qualified themselves as closers who
are worthy of those leads so the next
hack actually has again something to do
with things around sales but is not
sales itself which is most times it's
harder to get an entire team to go up by
30% in close rates unless you just
absolutely suck at sales but there's
usually massive opportunities on show up
rates and so one of the things that we
do is we give kudos or
shoutouts to the closers who have the
highest show up rates and so by calling
those people out we draw attention to
how show up rates are very important to
the business because if I had to give
you an option hey would you rather
increase your close rates by 20% or
increase your show rates by 20% Which
would you choose well if you're a smart
business owner you'd say Well they're
the same thing yes so then the followup
question is which one's more likely
given the stats you're at if your guys
are closing at 35% for you to get a 20%
boost might be very very difficult but
for you to just simply remind them to
work their leads and follow up with
their appointments might be very easy
and so you shout out the closers who
have the highest Strow rates every week
not just highest close rates and then
you ask them what they did and they're
probably going to say I just followed
the process and then you're going to say
that's awesome great job and if you want
you can give an extra kudos for the guy
who has the highest show up rate you can
give him like you know a $500 flat thing
per week whatever something that makes
it material enough that it's worth
showing off for but I'm telling you this
can increase your overall sales in your
business more than sales training can
sometimes and so if you're listening to
that you might be like okay well what is
the best reminder sequence for people to
show up now the first thing is is you
want to have your automated reminders
set up right those have to be done and
the thing is is and I think a lot of
people make this mistake is you want to
to look automated don't try and pretend
that automation is a real person
everyone knows and it looks like so
don't do it all right but on top of
automation you layer manual now manual
you don't have to nearly as much to make
it effective and hopefully I'm spelling
manual right all right and so there's
three times that we have S this is from
Allen that we know that gets the highest
show upates all right very simple 24
hours before all right then am and then
1 hour all right and so think about it
like this it's like you have your
automated ones until the night before
and someone says hey just making sure
that we're on for tomorrow very excited
I did this personalized thing for you
and so you want to show that you did
some sort of prep for the prospect so
they know you've put some effort in and
so they would feel worse about not
showing because you show that you've got
a whole bunch of work that you want to
show them on that call and so whether
you're a weight loss you know business
it's like hey I set aside this t-shirt
for you what size do you want or what
color do you want for when you come in
would be something that you could do for
a weight loss customer if you're a B2B
customer it's like hey I already I
looked over your site we already uh I
talked to my team about it it looks like
we've got three things we can
immediately help you with very excited
to share what we found like it takes 5
minutes to do that but if you can
increase your show up rate by 30%
because you do that makes a lot of sense
right in 60 minutes you can increase
your closure your total sales througha
by 30% once a day feels like it's worth
it now that's night before morning of
you think you're a prospect right you're
like okay yeah sounds good morning of
you start and your whole day is blank
because you forgot everything from the
day before and so the morning it's like
hey just reminder again I'm seeing you
later this afternoon and they're like
yep I'm in cool and then one hour before
they're busy during the day and you're
like yo a meeting with you in 60 minutes
just making sure now for these I prefer
to have uh blue messages is what we call
them but basically the IM messages
whenever possible rather than the green
ones because people still don't entirely
believe uh that it's a real person and
so this is where having uh voice voice
memos uh and video work really well for
those reminders in addition to the
things that you're doing at the 24-hour
Mark that show personalization so it
would be something like this hey John
really excited to meet with you tomorrow
we outlined six things for your business
that I think would really help you out
I'm very excited to share them with you
these were things that I pulled from my
team and just from looking at the site
uh before we get on the call so stoked
we're at 4:00 tomorrow hit me up if
there's any issues or you have any
problems getting on otherwise I'll see
you then next one is Logistics in terms
of how you schedule Andor your policies
which is we like to do same day next
day period in terms of our availability
now the reason for that is because show
up rates are higher same day next day
and so if we constrain people to those
days we increase the show up rates now
the key and this is where most people
mess up is that they're like well if I
did same day next day I'm not going to
be able to book all my appointments that
means you need to hire more sales people
and when you do that you'll get more
shows which then means you close more
sales so those are some immediate things
that you can do to multiply your sales
without even having to learn anything
more about what you have to say on the
phone or even getting good at sales
itself these are all the things you do
around sales that still close way more
sales than anything you can actually do
on the call but once you do get on the
call you should make sure that your guy
or you yourself don't suck so let's talk
about sales training so now that we've
covered sales multipliers now let's talk
about sales training making it happen so
I'm going to cover daily huddles one-on
ones gam tape review role playing and CS
gam tape weekly reviews all right you're
feel like I don't know what any of those
are that's why I made this video and
I'll break them down so number one is
most people have no idea what they're
doing when they're training sales so the
vast majority of sales organizations
don't even know how to train them at all
and simply just run shurn factories so
they say you know we'll bring 100 people
in we'll see who survives which fine but
if you know how to train sales as a
business owner you can compensate below
Market because you can take someone
who's not good and make them good rather
than relying on people to come in with
existing skills and so that is the
Arbitrage opportunity that you get to
have as a business owner and so if
someone comes in with no skills and then
you give them a lot of skills they come
in at that Baseline right now I'm not
saying that uh sales people shouldn't
make make a lot of money they should uh
but it's all based on the marketplace if
you have 10 times bigger audience that
you can take sales people from then
that's an advantage that you have
compared to your other businesses on the
marketplace of sales skills so the first
thing that we do is we like to have
daily huddles and so daily huddles are
where we do role playing now role
playing is probably the single greatest
skill that you need to learn in sales
and the big thing I'll give you as a
caveat is every entrepreneur or sales
managers always afraid of looking bad or
not being able to close something uh in
front of their team and so they they shy
away from doing role playing but you
need to set the frame up front which is
no one's perfect that's why we practice
and so I'm going to mess up you're going
to catch me and it's fine right because
if you have any ego around this you will
not do it as much because you'll be
afraid of looking stupid in front of
your team so just get over that as fast
as humanly possible now when you're
doing these daily huddles you want to do
the role playing so the role playing the
important part of role playing is you
actually have to get into it with them
and give Fast
feedback now here's how not to do it so
and this is how most people do it which
is someone goes through the script and
they give not real answers anyways and
then they say okay at the end of the 30
minutes or 20 minutes they say do this
different do that different do this
different do that different so two
massive problems number one is that you
have to give one piece of feedback at a
time people can't handle multiple piece
feedback so it's not going to work
second is that the trainability of a
person or really an organism because
this actually happens across species is
inversely correlated with how fast you
get feedback and so basically the number
of times that you have to uh give
feedback to an organism is inverted with
how quickly so one second 2 second 3
second whatever now this is an
exaggeration but this would be number of
times so that means that if I say Hey
try it like this and then they can't do
it again and then I have to say try it
like this and then they still can't do
it and then I say try it like this the
faster I do it the fewer times I have to
repeat myself before they get it and so
this is why speed is so important for
training this actually happens across
human you know across the entire
organization but specifically for sales
so when someone does the role play the
sales manager or the other person's only
working on one thing and when they begin
the sale they say this is what we're
working on
and then they start the role play and
then as soon as they mess up or do a
good job which both those are happening
in real time all the time you say great
keep going great keep going and so they
keep talking and they can see you
nodding your head they can see you
giving thumbs up and you can hear you
saying great and so you have three or
four different ways that you can give
positive reinforcement in real time so
that you can train them on the right
thing to say now when they do mess up
you also set the frame beforehand saying
listen I'm going to probably stop you 30
or 40 times times during you just trying
to say this one script that's okay
that's to be expected that means we're
doing it right and so if you set that
expectation people aren't thrown off
guard if you don't they're going to
think that they're just doing a horrible
job which is not what you want to do and
so they go through and you're like
awesome great job M keep it going pause
say it like this try it again great try
it
again great try it again and so once
someone properly does the right way of
saying it you don't just say great they
did it once you have them do it two
three four five six times in quick
succession so that it drills it in so
that when they actually are on a sales
call it's like this little mini recorder
plays and they remember when they to
drill it so many times in a row and from
a sales training perspective you want to
be working with them on one thing
sometimes for a week or two weeks all
right so it's not a big deal now daily
huddles you're usually working with the
team on something like as a team we're
struggling with this and so as a team
we're going to be drilling this on
101's it's one thing and it's going to
be specific to that person now the
reason that most sales managers do a bad
job sales training is because it's a
full-time job like you have to listen to
sales recordings you have to see what
they're messing up you have to take
notes and then when you meet with them
one-on-one you have to see all 28 things
you think they did wrong and say which
of these 28 things is going to create
the highest Improvement in their close
closing rate and then say we're only
going to prioritize this one thing so it
may be like they just don't know how to
ask for the card smoothly it may be that
they don't know how to set the agenda
well on the call it may be that they
lose the frame somewhere during the sale
it may be that they're getting lost in
the weeds when someone asks detail based
questions that they don't know how to
zoom out like these are all different
skills that a good salesman should know
how to do in a sale and you can only
focus on one of them so I'll give you
another one which is your best
closer usually
isn't your sales manager all right and
so this is a mistake that I've made
multiple times in my life and it's
because typically the best closers are
very like Hunter type person um and
there's nothing wrong with that I mean
hey that's what makes the world go
around um but often times they're not
like super like leadership oriented
patient willing to uh continue to invest
in teammates like they just want to
close deals and so most times most
closers that I've had in our businesses
before I explain this to them they're
like I want to be sales manager somay
and I'm like do you know what the
day-to-day of a sales manager is because
it's not just like oh this makes me more
money it's your entire activities that
you do all the things you love about
this job are now going to stop and be a
whole new set of things and so sometimes
the best closers it's kind of like
coaches it's like it's not the best
players who sometimes make the best
coaches sometimes it's like mediocre or
bad players who just learned how to be
decent or good not the best best who
actually make the best coaches and so I
set this stage what I said earlier which
is like the sales manager has to have no
egoo and can set the stage which is like
hey some of you guys are better than me
at sales like and so for example Phil
Jackson is not better than Michael
Jordan or kobby Bryant at basketball but
they respected when he gave them
feedback on their work and so I would
even use that as a sales manager to set
the stage was like I hope that you guys
are better than me at sales because
that's what you have to do every day you
just make not be better than me at
helping other people get better at sales
and so these are different skills and
it's totally okay and so when I roleplay
with you if you smash me that's awesome
that's fine if Phil Jackson went
one-onone with MJ he's gon to get
destroyed every time that's fine my goal
is that this team crushes as a team the
next one that a lot of people don't
understand is about competition all
right now I think competition is very
good but not in the way that you think
it is so I used to be really hardcore
and Cutthroat about I wanted all my
teams you know the guys to compete like
you know let the let the winners win
losers lose Etc and I do but in a
different way so I don't want it to be
us versus ourselves I want the
competition to be us versus them so you
need to pick a big enemy and it doesn't
even have to mean that you actually are
enemies with this person it could be a
rival or friend ofy whatever you want
and say listen every customer that we're
not selling they're selling and so we
want to beat them right the reason that
you know the us could get to the moon
first because we were trying to beat the
Russians right like having uh a common
enemy is a great thing to align the
troops towards achieving a big goal and
it kind of quells the inner conflict of
the team but if everyone's trying to
Edge each other out it creates a culture
that in my opinion doesn't actually make
the most total sales you'll definitely
have people who thrive in those ultra
competitive environments but you will
lose people who otherwise would have
been good closers in a team environment
another amazing sales training piece
that we like to do in our companies is
gam tape review so first off you
absolutely need to be recording every
single call that happens to the customer
across the company across the life cycle
of the customer if you're not doing that
you should do it please do it now stop
the video go do this now all right now
assuming you are recording all calls
this is something that completely
changed my business forever was getting
sales and
Cs on the same call every
week to review the game tape and so
you're like why would you review sales
game tape with customer success on the
call well because then you can say hey
guys when you say it this way they
expect this and it's really bad for the
business and so what it does is actually
elevates both teams to a larger
perspective so they understand that like
when if you ever have conflict where CS
is like sales is over promising and
sales is like CS stop being such babies
and just do stuff right like we're the
ones who make the money like everyone
gets it we've all been there and so the
idea is when you get the them both on
the same call one of the other nice
things is that you then review an
onboarding call most salesp people have
never seen an onboarding call they've
been selling for you for three years
five years and they literally have no
idea what happens after they click
submit or they run the card or they send
the invoice over to finance and then
they get the car you know the approval
for their commission they're like all
right next Prospect and that's fine but
they have to understand kind of the
larger life cycle of the customer and so
this is what ends up happening the first
time sales seeson onboarding they're
like oh dude this is awesome this is so
good oh I'm going to use this in my
right they actually get way more data
that arms them to be more knowledgeable
in the sale and increases their
conviction as a closer for the business
because they believe in it and CS is can
look at the sales and be like hey now I
understand why they're coming in with
these expectations and they can give
sales the feedback of like hey do you
think if you sit it like this it would
change the sale a lot of guys like oh no
I don't know I just said it that way I
didn't know that they were coming in
that way and so what happens is you
create this really seamless process
between sales and Cs and you stop having
those drop offs and cold feet where
you're losing 5% of your sales or 10% of
your sales for people who close and then
back out and so that in a very real way
will increase your sales by decreasing a
negative I learned this from my software
days so when I started with Allen which
is the first software company I ever
owned um I learned from the software
world that they started doing these CS
to sales gam tape reviews and so we said
okay well if all these really big
companies that make more money than us
do this we'll give it a shot and as soon
as we did it and that first call
happened where we had the whole sales
team and the whole customer success team
on I was like oh I get it now like
everyone got a holistic view of the
customer Journey sales expectations were
better and cleaner uh they were more
knowledgeable about what the customer
Journey was going to be uh CS stopped
getting upset at sales for making
promises and it also helped because then
the Cs side was like Hey would it help
you if we did this one extra thing and
the sales guys are like dude everyone
asked for that they're like oh wouldn't
even be that hard for us to do and then
boom both sides get better they're
setting better expectations and they're
giving customers what they want more and
the Cs team didn't know because the
sales team said they couldn't do it
because they weren't communicating now
on recording sales which of course you
should do and you promise you'll do no
matter what after this video is done for
sure that's Pinky Promise that's what
you're going to start doing all right
now the next thing is what sales should
I watch all right and so this is my big
tip is there is no mysticism in sales
there's a lot of like you know it's kind
of like baseball they're like these are
my lucky socks or like I always touch
the phone here and here because uh I
close when I do that thing right there's
a lot of superstition that starts to
happen in sales because there's such fat
feed fast feedback loops so people learn
because they change their behavior uh
because it worked before and so they try
and do it again but they end up adding
all these rituals to their sales
processes that end up longterm actually
eroding uh their ability to sell all
right so they start adding all these
appendages to their sales process and
actually gets really cluttered and it
starts sucking all right now the biggest
hack that I can give you as an
individual salesperson is is that there
are times when you're hot all right
where you're like dude I feel like I
could close everyone today right you you
know it you're on fire when you're hot
record the living hell out of that and
rewatch those game tapes because you
aren't on fire you're doing things
slightly differently it means that your
Tone's a little different how you open's
a little bit different how you
transition to the Clos is a little bit
different and all you want to do is you
want to look for the details because the
big difference between good closes and
great closers is that good closers try
and get hot great closers never get cold
and it's because they've systematized
every single thing on their monster
checklist that creates the hotness of
their closing and so if you ever do get
hot know that you now have the potential
to close at that closing rate and then
say cool I'm going to analyze the living
hell out of what it looks like when I'm
hot how I say it where I pause where my
tone shifts where I ask my questions how
like when I transition to the sale how I
frame my overcomes how I'm punching back
and pushing back earlier in the sale to
overcome objections earlier before I
asked for money that is probably one of
the biggest RI tactics I can give you
either as a sales manager for your teams
or you as a sales professional just
record everything and when you're hot
analyze the living hell out of it next
one is also big team management stuff
which if you're ever in a slump so this
is for sales managers
specifically or entrepreneurs is that if
you're in a slump one of the easiest
things to do is start drilling
everything and sure you can do all that
stuff but in my experience reading
testimonials can be one of the biggest
things that you can do to increase the
conviction of the team and so you can
get someone's tone to be correct by lots
of drilling and lots of training but if
they are convicted they will always have
the correct tonality because they
genuinely believe in the product and
they genuinely believe it will help the
customer and so I like to train
competence in tone emphasis pacing I
like someone to understand all of those
things so they know what it looks like
when it's right but there's nothing that
replaces A salesperson who's actually
convicted because either you have a team
of sociopaths who don't care at all but
know how to say everything the exact
right way or you just have a team of
people who really believe in the product
and by believing the product they say
things the right way and I will tell you
personally it's way easier to find these
people than these people and so read
testimonials and then give
kudos to the
salesperson who Clos the prospect who
got the great result and so imagine this
you closed Sandy you know four weeks ago
and you had to arm wrestler into closing
she was super you know worried or
concerned but you overcame that and then
four weeks later you read a testimonial
from your manager who's like hey here's
Sandy saying like I'm so grateful that I
signed up for this thing it's completely
changed my life it's changed my business
I've lost weight whatever it is and and
you then as the salesman say Tom I know
I saw this call and I saw you arm
wrestle Sandy to get to get this deal
like awesome job because if you hadn't
done that if you hadn't stayed in the
pocket she wouldn't have this outcome
and so I learned this because I figured
out that my sales team had the highest
absurd closing percentage like 100% like
absurd closing percentages on one
specific day of the month when I had my
gyms and I was like what is it about
this day do you want to know what day it
was it was we out day and so when we'd
run our challenges every week we would
have people who'd be weighing out from
six weeks earlier and so on Friday or
Saturday we'd have way outs and so it'd
be people coming in for 15-minute
appointments and weighing out taking
their after pictures weighing out taking
their after pictures and after someone
saw 20 people lose 20 pounds 30 pounds
whatever it was in that time period when
someone would come in between those
weigh-ins or after those weigh-ins and
they're like I'm thinking about signing
up they had absolute conviction in the
fact that it was going to help them
because they had just recently that day
hours or minutes before seen 5 10 20
people literally demonstrate results in
front of them and so that conviction
they passed the Prospect and so I just
like to remind you of this if you are a
salesperson is that sales is passing
conviction from one person to another
it's an education process over a bridge
of trust and so fundamentally if a
prospect knew everything that you know
about the product they should buy now if
they knew everything that you know and
then they wouldn't Buy and you get them
to buy it means that you deceive them
which means that you are an unethical
salesperson so don't do that and so the
idea is that you want to just basically
fill in the fewest gaps you need to in
order to get them over the bridge they
say yes I know enough to make this
decision and now I want to buy now that
we've covered sales training let's talk
about what happens before the sale which
yes is absolutely part of the sale so
the first thing that a lot of people
Miss up is that the sale Begins the
moment the customer engages with your
business not the moment they get on the
phone and so how the interaction and
communication happens between click and
call Will massively change your close
rates on the team independent of what
you say so for example if you're a local
business and when you call to book the
lead you say hey uh before you get going
did you hear about us on uh you know
local City's best boot camp list or that
we won this thing three years in a row
is that how you heard about us now if
they're like no I heard about you from a
Facebook ad you still asking that
question will influence what the
customer uh perceives about your
business and then we'll be like oh wow I
I didn't know that they won that stuff
and so the questions you ask can still
be educational and frame how you exist
in the marketplace to a prospect before
you even beun selling them because you
have begun selling them and so the thing
is is that the sale
starts
at the click all right so the setting
script the ad they see
all
influence whether they're going to buy
and so this is where having continuity
and having a seamless experience between
this whole thing is what will overall
increase your closing percentage as a
team again prior to even talking to them
for the main sale so the next thing is
like okay what else can I do before the
sale that increases the likelihood that
someone closes and so the big obvious
one and ke de talks about this in his
influence book is edifying the closer so
if I am setting a call and I've already
edified the business by saying something
like hey we were on you know so and so's
list now a lot of people want to get on
those lists because they think the list
is going to somehow get them business no
the list isn't going to get you business
but telling people that you were on the
list will get you business and so that's
where and let's be real you usually just
pay five grand to the magazine so that
they put you on the list of best boot
camps in local area or best accounting
firm in local area or state whatever
then that edified the business now when
I'm qualifying the prospect I say oh I'm
going to put you on with Shawn Shawn's
unbelievable he help 400 people just
like you get to thing that you just said
you wanted in your specific
circumstances recently for example he
helped someone just like you achieve
this and this someone else like you
achieve this and this and so you're
going to love talking to him he's a
great guy and he's going to help you out
oh you know what I think he has an
opening this afternoon let me see if I
can get you in hold on two seconds
making noise in the background yep he
confirmed we're good to go four o00
Works awesome and so if you have that
versus yeah uh I got you down for four
one of our team will be reaching out
imagine the difference in terms of how
that Prospect has been pre-framed to
talk to that closer now the closer when
they start the call have to maintain
that frame that the set are set but
again this is all creating one seamless
experience of we are on top of it we are
a legitimate business and we are someone
you want to do business with the next
thing is the qualification process so a
lot of people have said a lot of things
about qualification but the nice thing
is that IBM did this massive study and
then came up with bant and bant is an
acronym that stands for
Budget
Authority
need
timing and so they said that for a lead
to be qualified for an account rep or
close closer the setter had to make sure
that they had ban they had to make sure
that the person had the budget they had
the authority to make the decision they
had the need they had the problem to
solve and they had the timing meaning
they wanted to get started soon and so
those fundamentally are the things that
are required to close a sale and so you
can do this on the call you can also do
this on the application that you have
prior to the call and even if you did
that on both you'll still probably have
to say yet again on the closing call but
you want to say it before you ask for
money and so fundamentally you're making
sure the problem the person has the
problem to solve the money to spend the
time to do the implementation and the
authority to make the decision and
people will say yes to it and then
change their mind when you ask for money
but we'll get to that later now this
section isn't about outbound per se but
I couldn't help but give you one of my
favorite outbound scripts I've ever
heard which is hey business I'm calling
about competitor period give me a call
back so think about this imagine you
have a dry cleaning business and it's
Tom's dry cleaners that's you and you've
got Jones uh because you're keeping up
with the Joneses Jones dry cleaning
across the street and you get a call
being like hey um this is Alex I'm
calling in regards to Janes dry cleaning
uh give me a call back when it's
convenient you're like so incredibly
curious that somebody has left a message
and they want to talk about your
competition and so imagine that versus
hey I'm calling from 123 Financial
wanted to see if you wanted to work like
no one gives a right but because
you have this personalized uh message
that you're sending which works via
email it also works via uh voicemail uh
the likelihood that the respond is way
way higher now when the person comes on
and they're like hey what about whatever
it's like oh it looks like they're
kicking your ass and so or hey I see
that they're in the same industry as you
and we've reached out to them as well
and then so like it's it's a very easy
Bridge into whatever you want to say
when you get into your when you actually
get into the conversation but the
response rates from
hey
x uh
calling regarding
competitor slays and while we're on the
topic of how to work leads let me give
you my favorite scripting for calling up
leads for local business when someone
opts in and so the way that I do this so
this is local
leads so when I call a lead or called a
lead and I called many of them uh I
wouldn't say hey John this is Alex I
want to see when you want to come in for
like no that's not going to work all
right so even though they already showed
interest they usually don't even know
who you are when you're calling all
right so the way I would do it is this
so I would call and I would say John not
is this John I would say John question
no my tone goes up pause and then he's
John is gonna be like yeah uh who's this
like this is Alex pause he's thinking
who is Alex who like how like and I'm
acting with the way that I'm I'm toning
toning uh that he should know who I am
all right that's the tone that I'm that
I'm bringing this it's Alex
pause and during the pause I can hear
them it's like I'm calling you because
you opted in on Facebook for our
promotion and so I just wanted to make
sure that one you weren't a crazy person
on the internet ha and if there was a
time that worked well for you to come in
and obviously to make sure that you knew
that we weren't crazy people either
right and so just in that little opener
we have we pull them in we pull them in
again then we quickly like you steamroll
this you go as fast as you can and say
Hey you opted in for that thing on
Facebook this specific promotion it's
like I'm giving them three different
kind of mental cues around what they
opted in for because people don't
remember the things they opt in for and
especially if you don't call your leads
within one minute then you call them two
days later they're in a different
Universe at this point they have no idea
what they opted in for and they might
have opted in for 10 things so they have
no clue what you're talking about and so
then you can then bring them in and
schedule time I wanted to figure out a
time that would work well for you to
come in I've got 2:00 and 4:00 today
which works better all right and so by
doing that I'm also giving two options
and saying which do you prefer rather
than saying asking them to pick a time I
look at my schedule I see my openings I
present two openings that both work for
me and then they pick and if you want to
hear a little little little little early
Alex story um when I started my gym I
used to pretend that I there were
multiple employees that worked at my gym
and I would be like this is John and
then when they come in be like oh you're
G to love Alex Alex is the amazing he's
totally going to help you out he's
helped out so many people just like you
at same same edification script they
come in and they'd be like you sound a
lot like John be like we get it all the
time and we go into it um but
alternatively uh you cannot do that if
you don't want to I was young and uh I
thought it was fun and uh to me and you
know what I was deceiving people and so
that is wrong uh but to me that's a
little bit of a white FIB of a
23-year-old gym owner trying to trying
to make it happen and the last one and
this one is so unsexy and because it's
so unsexy no one does it which is why
you make so much money doing this which
is you prep for five minutes before the
call looking up stuff about the person
or the business and so if you're a
Setter you can do this for the closer or
closer you can do this for yourself
prior to the call but you would be
amazed at how much of a genius you look
like with five minutes of prep people
are like wow this guy really did his
homework and it's not because you really
did that much homework it's just because
everyone else is so lazy that any level
of effort looks amazing all right and so
the five minutes of prep in addition to
and this is clear all the notes that the
setter sets should be in the CRM so that
when you go up with the prospect you
want to say Hey so uh you know Jimmy
earlier was telling me that you're X Y
and Z and that you've done this and
you've done this got it so it's this is
it fair to say that this is where you're
currently at right now this what you're
trying to achieve great well this sounds
like this would be a good call for you
and I think we're we're going to we're
going to figure something out together
whatever right and so the thing is is
that you never want a customer to repeat
themselves right that's not a good
experience experience overall and the
flip side is it's kind of like binary
like repeating is really negative but
you repeating to them what they told you
is exceptionally positive and so it's
this really binary swing in terms of
like this can hurt the sale this will
help the sale and so it takes five
minutes and most of the time you should
be taking notes on your sales calls
anyway so that you can look like you're
actively listening which you should be
and that way guess what happens to those
notes after the closer closes they get
passed on to customer success and then
they say so I you talked to Steve you
talk to Jim and these are the things
that you decided on I think we're going
to be able to help you out with insert
goal and the way that we're going to
help you insert goal is by following
step one two three so let's get started
right and so by setting this seamless
experience from click to close from
Setter to closer to to onboarding you
create an amazing process for prospects
to go through and again you can solve so
much of this and blow prospects Away by
just preparing for 5 minutes and either
you do the research or you at least read
the notes before the call the next one's
a small one but we have one in our sales
room which is uh a mini trampoline and
so I used to take 20 25 in-person sales
sales consults per day and so that could
be very tiring and on my really Hercules
days I would see 4850 people oneon-one
or one on two uh every 30 minutes right
and so I would get exhaust so one on1
102 for 12 hours is 48 um is what I
would do is I would do little mini J
trampoline jumps between sessions to
kind of keep my energy up and mostly to
keep my mood up because I would start to
get beat down when you have your 25th or
30th conversation that the exact same
conversation of the day it starts to
drain you and so what I figured out was
you cannot be in a bad mood and jumping
on a trampoline at the same time so try
it like seriously you can jump on a TR
like you can't even do it and frown it's
ridiculous but it really works and so I
did it and I highly recommend it if
you're somebody who struggles to keep
your energy up or keep your tone
positive
uh when you have like a long sales day
now that we covered what happened before
the sale now let's talk about the actual
sale as it begins opening up the sales
conversation you need to as quickly as
possible set the agenda of what's going
to happen so I actually think a lot
about proof promise plan just like we do
for YouTube videos just like we do for
short content because humans are still
humans their attention still works the
same way and just like the opener to a
piece of content can dictate how well
the entire video goes or How likely
someone is to pay attention the same
thing is true about how you open a sales
call and so think of every single thing
that I'm going to talk about for this
whole portion about as things that
increase the likelihood that someone
purchases and so fundamentally it's my
belief that the way sales work is that
we have 100 golden BBS we have a 100
tiny things that each of them increases
the likelihood that someone purchases
and so I will share this one perspective
with you on sales then we'll get into it
which is BF Skinner who's a behavioral
psychologist said this quote he said
people say you can lead a horse to water
you can't make a drink he said I
wholeheartedly disagree he said if I
dehydrated the horse bled it out and
salted its mouth and I put water right
in front of it when it's on the ground
on a hot day he said I can veritably
guarantee that it will drink and I kind
of see sales the same way which is that
if you control every single variable you
could in theory close every single
Prospect and so I like to think about it
that way as though all of these things
are under my control so I start sales
the same way that I start content which
is proof promise
plan and fundamentally I do this because
I believe that humans are humans and if
you want to gain someone's attention and
have authority and have them want to
wait until the end then if you can do it
that way when you're not there to
reinforce them or force them to stay on
the call and you still get people to
stay to the end then this absolutely
works when you're also there to
reinforce them on the call and keep them
going to the end and so I actually think
this is one of the easiest ways and
proof promise plan only takes 15 seconds
maybe 20 so you can absolutely get to
the point and so when you start on a
sales call it works more or less the
same way which is John decided to get
get going with you on this thing this
big promise that we're working on uh
we've done this with lots of other
people who are just like you and so this
is the process that we're going to do
and at the end of the call we're to see
if it makes sense to move forward if not
no sweat I'm going to still send you on
your way with stuff that could help you
with the problem overall right and so by
doing that we still set out our proof
promise plan right at the beginning and
what I have found in my opinion one
man's opinion is that you actually gain
more report I actually got on a sales
call uh yesterday with uh a banker for
one of the portfolio companies and they
were trying to bring our business over
and uh he said hey if you don't mind can
we just skip the foreplay and I was like
I I just immediately was like I love you
for saying that and he's like let's just
get right to it and then he set the
agenda and it was awesome and so I could
tell obviously he was a super you know
very very hot multi-million dollar
preyear salesperson because we have big
counts uh and so the same thing is True
For You especially if you sell B2B like
get to the point and when you set theend
that way you actually control the frame
because you told them how this call is
going to go and if you don't know how
the call is going to go you don't know
what you're doing and then it looks like
an increased likelihood that you waste
that person's time and so you having an
agenda also shows that you have done
this before that you're a professional
that you know what you're doing so the
next one is follow the script so I
actually asked my sales team uh to tell
me I said what are the things that I
shout at you guys that uh that have
helped you a lot so some of these isms
are directly from the horse's mouth via
other horses horsing it back to the
horse uh but I I say follow the I'll put
a little asteris here follow the
script now the reason I I want to
highlight this is that if your team does
not follow the script there is no point
in having a script and so script
adherence in my opinion is the first
thing that you drill I would rather have
100% of my team saying the script word
for word and Us close no one because
then I could then close change the
script and then get everyone to close
because if everyone follows the script
and doesn't close you have a script
problem if people aren't following the
script you can't change anything because
then you have to do it all onesie TWY
all over the place now to be clear a the
script is basically up to the ask after
the ask you have the loops that you're
going to do the overcomes that you're
going to drill with them and sometimes
that leads you down a different
Christmas tree but the first part of the
sale the first two-thirds of the sale
should be pretty much word for word the
same their answers will change but the
actual scripting Remains the Same so
there's different levels of following
the script the very surface of that
would be actually just saying the words
but there are a lot of other things in
communication like if I slow down what
I'm saying right now it sounds really
important and if I speed up what I'm
saying what it sounds is going to be
really like interesting and I'm very
excited about I'm transferring that to
you and you might increase the speedo as
you're approaching the close but then
when you go for the ask you might slow
down you might lower your voice again
and the thing is is that you can also
change the meaning of a sentence by
changing how you say it so I got this
from Jason F FL was a good
um and he said and I love this one I
didn't say he hit his wife which implies
that I wasn't the one who said it I
didn't say he hit his wife I didn't say
he hit his wife I didn't say he hit his
wife I didn't say he hit his wife I
didn't say he hit his wife I didn't say
it his wife each of those sentences are
all the same exact words but mean very
different things and so one is you can
change the meaning of a sentence by
where you emphasize the next is your
ality so me going low or me going high
both of those things can change what a
sentence means so if I say a statement
like you're doing 3 million a year
versus you're doing three million a year
those are two very different things one
is a question asking somebody to respond
back and the other is me just making a
statement and then moving on and so you
can increase or increase the tone of
your voice at the end of a sentence
which then implies that you're asking
for a response from the Prospect and so
one is you have emphasis which is where
am I going to
pause the second is that you have tone
which is am I going to go low am I going
to go high and how is it going to change
throughout the sentence and then finally
you have pacing where do I slow down
when I really want to make sure that you
hear every word that I'm saying because
it's very important and this is a matter
OFA tone to increase trust with the
prospect because what I'm sharing is
something that I haven't told other
people or whatever right and so pacing
can go slow and fast toning can go up
and down emphasis is where you pause and
so when you're following the script or
making the script you want the script to
have a tone guide with it and so you
could have XY z w as the words and you
can use the things on a word processor
AKA Google Docs or whatever you type
stuff on and you can say if I underline
it means slow down if I put this in all
caps then it means emphasize this if I
put this in italics then it means create
space whatever so so the nice thing is
that on word processors you have
underline italics bold and caps and so
those things give you four different
kind of cues for the closer so that when
they're reading the script they know how
they're supposed to read the script and
so when you're drilling the first thing
you're going for is actually saying the
right words once you have a team that
can breathe the script which they should
do very quickly because it's not that
many words you should only be looking at
you know 12 questions that you might be
asking maybe one follow-up or two for
the questions not something that's like
the Gettysburg address here right which
you still memorized when you were in
sixth grade anyways and so and you did
it for free rather than getting paid for
it all right here the 2011 version of
following the script is saying the words
the way they need to be said in order to
increase the likelihood that the person
buys all right so now that we have okay
you have to follow the words we
emphasize tone and pacing we can write
the script in a way that helps the
closers uh have the right tone at each
portion of the sale then we can move on
to the actual scripting itself now I
have used something called The Closer
framework for a long time I don't think
that this is magical it just is an
acronym that people remember more than
anything um and if people remember it
then it means it's been effective at
teaching them because if they remember
it then it changes their behavior they
have learned and so there are probably
more complex ways we have a different
scripting process that I call the
diagnostic script I've made a big video
about that but for the vast majority of
sales calls that are specifically
transactional so it's one call two call
closes I usually follow this structure
and so the C stands for clarify why they
are here all right and so if you get on
the phone and someone says I just want
to have more information people don't
get on the phone to get more information
no one wants to learn stuff people get
on the phone because they want to solve
a problem and so we need to get really
clear we clarify the problem that
they're like why are you here this is
that the question that we're answering
now it's like why'd you take the time to
hop on the call today what made you
reach out to us what made you op on the
site and what you want to ask in these
types of questions that are clarifying
the problem are reminding them of
actions they took to show up on your
call and so the thing is is even if
you're outbow no matter what every lead
that you talk to is engaged meaning
they've taken one action towards you so
hey what made you what made you comment
on my post what made you respond to my
email what made you set a call on my
calendar no matter what it is what made
you pick up the phone and and keep
listening to me like they've always done
something to uh now obviously if you're
in a close you're probably not closing
on on a cold first Outreach right um
they've done something at this point to
indicate interest and we will remind
them of the interest and then tie that
to a problem they're trying to solve all
right then we label them now I this is
like the shortest part of the script but
it's incredibly important all right
which is you label them with that
problem so you've clarified it but you
said okay so just to make sure I'm clear
you are here you want to get here and
this has been the issue that's been
holding you back what you're essentially
doing is establishing the gap between
present and desired and sometimes the
obstacle that they believe is standing
in their way once you have that you have
now set the table for making a sale
because now you have this is where you
want this is where you are this is where
you want and we've got this big dragon I
think I can give you the sword to slay
it or I can slay it for you whatever the
next part of the sale is overviewing
past pain now the reason the overview of
the pain is so important I call the pain
cycle is something that I've actually
only learned about I I learned this
while I was selling I just knew that
talking about people's pain and what
they done before got more people to buy
I didn't know why I just knew that that
ended up always being the case now later
I know a little bit more about sales uh
and more just human behavior and
deprivation creates motivation and so if
I am hungry I am motivated to eat if I'm
tired I'm deprived of sleep means I'm
motivated to sleep if I am if I haven't
seen my wife in a few days I might be
motivated to do other things you get the
idea if you're deprived You Are by
definition motivated to end the
deprivation and so what we want to do in
the sales call is basically expand the
deprivation we want to bring their state
of deprivation to top of mind so that in
the moment we can increase their
deprivation which then rubber bands back
to increasing motivation to solve it and
so if you've probably seen you know
political polls where they're like
what's the topic of this election what
they do is they specifically choose
topics to deprive the population of so
that we say this is now more important
for us it's not that education isn't
important but for apparently this
election it's not no one's talked about
education right but in different
elections they've been like this is a
big problem and so then that becomes the
thing that everyone talks about and then
that's the main reason people choose the
people that they're going to elect and
so this deprivation motivates a change
in behavior and within the context of
sales that means taking the action to
move forward in the sales process or
taking the action to buy this is why the
pain cycle is so important and so I have
a little ISM that I have in my sales
team which is the pain is the pitch like
the pain is the thing that often it's
the Gap we have to make sure that they
have it's like well I tried this thing
and I tried this thing and I tried this
thing and so we want to quantify how
much they've spent so far in time and
effort and what the impact that's been
on their status within their community
and how much it's costing them to not do
this every day so this is the cost of
inaction or the cost of failure every
single day that they don't achieve this
thing whatever it is that they want and
the reason we highlight those pains is
because it creates urgency it creates an
increased likelihood that they act so
the pain cycle that I ran with like
weight loss for examples what have you
done so far to try and lose weight and
then when someone would say I did Weight
Watchers or I did you know whatever it
didn't matter I knew what my pitch was
going to be because I had a three
three-pillar pitch which we'll get to in
the S we which I would always try and
highlight the good things of the things
they did and the things that it was
missing when they brought it up and so
if someone said hey I did you know
Weight Watchers I would say great so
they gave you nutrition I was like but
I'm guessing you kind of bounc back now
remember everything they've done is an
advantage for you because they are here
in the sale which means it did not solve
the problem and so I remember even
having somebody came in who's like I
already have a personal trainer and I'm
like yeah he's obviously not doing a
good job but she just looked at me
sideways I was like you're here and so
she was like fair right and so then I
closed the sale but the thing is is that
so you know Weight Watchers was they had
nutrition and they had accountability
but they didn't have Fitness right and
so you lost the weight then you gained
it back because you lost muscle when you
did it oh that's why it didn't work six
from gold all we have to do is fix this
one thing and then we can get you
success uh oh I did the gyms before but
it didn't work for me well did they give
you a personalized food plant well you
know what they did okay did they hold
you accountable to doing it no they
didn't okay so you had Fitness and
Nutrition you didn't have accountability
because if you have Fitness Nutrition
and accountability you can't fail
fundamentally if you eat the food you
work the work the working out and this
actually makes sure you do the first two
you're going to lose the weight right
and so every business has I call a
three-pillar pitch that's buried inside
of it so I was making I always tell the
story because it's a fun one but I was
making a sales script for a marketing
company that was selling leads to
mortgage brokers and Realtors I spent
the whole morning being like what are
the three things like what are the three
things that makes an amazing lead and so
it's like okay well you want and I came
up with you want leads to be timely you
want leads to be uh qualified and you
want them to be exclusive right and so
basically it's like it's basically going
through b it's like you want them to
have the budget you want them to have
the timing and you want them to have uh
the authority and or need right and so
obviously the need was established
because they were leads in already
indicated interest right and so was
really just controlling for the other
three in the three-pillar pitch and so
when we were talking and so when we
scripted it out it's like oh have you
ever done have you ever bought leads in
the past and if they had and obviously
they weren't having a good experience
because they were on the phone with us
be like oh what was it and all we had to
do was pick out oh you you were getting
leads from Zillow but they weren't
exclusive to you right and so you had to
compete with 20 other guys so you had
good quality leads they had the budget
and they had the interest and presumably
the authority to make a decision right
but but they weren't exclusive to you
and so that was the problem and if You'
had leads that were exclusive do you
think you'd be able to make money
they're like oh my God if I had an
exclusive it would been great you're
like awesome boom established the Gap
figured out the poll in between boom we
can pull him over we can help you out
right and so every pitch usually now to
be very clear I'm not saying that it's
always three things that triangulate a
sale I'm saying that humans tend to
think in threes and so when I make a
sales pitch I try and chunk up to the
three big things so you might be like
well we have a seven-step process it's
like fine Chunk Up Until It's three so
nutrition I could break down into like
okay well we've got calories we've got
macronutrients we got micronutrients
we've got meal timing we've got meal
composition like I could get it I could
get as fancy as we wanted to to create
more components but you just want to
chunk up to three because people tend to
remember it now when you get to the S
which is the sell the vacation which
I've already kind of gotten
into we want to talk about the vacation
we want to talk about Maui we don't want
to talk about the plane flight we don't
want to talk about TSA we don't to talk
about taking shoes off going through
security you know getting padded down uh
how how bumpy and you know it's going to
be on the on the plane the food you're
going to have to eat the person sitting
next to you is going to smell bad like
we don't want to talk about any of that
we want to talk about Maui we want to
talk about the experience of what it
will be like when they've accomplished
the thing the the transformation that
we're selling whatever it is now when we
have the three-pillar pitch I like to
make the statement of what you need like
exclusive right or it needs to be
nutrition you need to have whatever the
pillar is you make the statement and
then you give the metaphor all right and
so this is how I do my three-pillar
pitches and normally a three-pillar
pitch shouldn't be longer than 2 minutes
and so if you're like wait a second
so this whole sale I'm only going to be
talking about my product for like two
minutes yep because you want to be
talking about the prospect not the
product and so if I want to get into a
new organization and I want to figure
out how to sell I'm going to spend 90%
of my time trying to understand the
pains remember for motivation the Pains
of the Prospect and once you know the
Pains of a prospect and this is me just
you know taking my ethical disclaimer
hat on you can sell them
anything because fundamentally if you
know where someone is and you know where
they want to go and you know the things
things they've struggled with if I
wanted to sell supplements you just sell
that as the bridge between where they're
at and where they want to go or you sell
nutrition coaching or you sell Fitness
or you sell all three it doesn't really
matter you could sell your piece of
equipment either way you're going to
have where they're at where they want to
go difficulties they've had and then you
just Bridge it with the product but most
sales teams spend all their time trying
to train people on the product and not
the Prospect and so then they sound
really ill-informed and ask stupid
questions that anybody who knew more
about the prospect would already know
the answer to it so I'll give you three
of my my favorite kind of metaphors um
that I used to use around uh
accountability uh and so I had the
three-pillar pitch one is I would just
the fact that I would call it the
three-pillar pitch I call the three legs
the stool and so I was like you can have
if you have two then the stool Falls
over right you can maybe balance it for
a little bit maybe you did do nutrition
and accountability for a little bit with
Weight Watchers you lost 50 but you G
back 60 and they like yeah like right so
you had it it balanced but then it fell
over right but if you have all three and
I could use my hands and I would show
them that then they'd be like oh I get
it it's like yeah this is what you need
in order to be successful this so I make
an analogy or metaphor of what the three
pillars that we have and how it relates
to something that's a strong structure
now does the Dynamics of how a stool
stands have anything to do with SEO or
how we get leads from mortgage brokers
no but it helps people understand and so
fundamentally what a metaphor is is it
Compares something they don't understand
your thing that you sell with something
they do understand and you make
parallels fundamentally by the way this
is what teaching is and so if we want to
have a metaphor so I use I use these two
for accountability which absolutely slay
one I got from Alison Prince the other
one I got from Tom Miller so I'll give
you the toothbrush one so you say hey uh
when you were a kid did you hate
brushing your teeth right all of a said
or if they have kids it's like do your
kids hate brushing their teeth yeah of
course but you know and so every night
you're like hey brush your teeth they
like brush the teeth and they go to bed
and now you're an adult do you brush
your teeth now and the answer is yes
most people do if you have a weirdo then
maybe you shouldn't sell them anyways so
you brush your teeth now of course okay
so what happened was in the beginning
you had external accountability your
parent was your coach saying hey kept
reminding you kept reminding you kept
reminding you and then over time the
positive reinforcement of doing the
behavior became the internal motivation
to stick with it and so what we're doing
is we're going to artificially become
that external motivation that you need
in the beginning to create the Habit so
that you can do this long term right now
that's I would sell accountability and
so me saying that notice I'm not saying
hey we're going to reach out to you this
many days and we're going to be on this
channel of communication these are the
the response times I just say big
picture you didn't brush your teeth and
you hated it and now you brush your
teeth and you don't miss a day and the
big thing that was the difference was
this thing and that's what we're going
to provide to you done then a different
version of this was uh The Amazing Race
in The Amazing Race uh they actually had
to change the rules because there was a
couple that won too many times that they
had had to say they had to dismantle
their advantage you know what the
advantage was well what they would do is
whenever they get dropped off this new
area they would find a local person put
him in the back seat pay him for the day
and say hey help us get to this place
and because they had a local they beat
everyone else who tried to do it on
their own and so what I want to do right
now is I've been to where you're going
and I've been in the backseat with a
hundred other people just like you and I
can be your backseat driver because
it'll give you an unfair advantage that
makes sense done you've already moved on
from the pillar right and so that's how
you explain that's those are two
metaphors to explain something right and
if I sold supplements I would give
metaphors around uh you know protein or
whatever right and so the whole idea is
that you want to know what your three
pillar are and then you want to know uh
an analogy that makes it more relevant
if I was selling SEO I'd be like hey
well think about your ads as your
paycheck that you get every month you
have to put you have to put work in make
new ads put money in but you get money
out immediately think about SEO like an
investment account you're going to put
money in but it's not really going to be
much for a while but eventually it
starts compounding and then within one
year or two years it's going to be
bigger than anything you could do
actively right but it just takes time so
it's just like an investment account
right and so that's my analogy so you've
got SEO and paid traffic it's the same
as income and investment right and so
whatever the three things that you're
selling are you just want to have a
clear analogy that someone can just say
got it because if you start getting into
details you get into the weeds and
that's where you die and by the way if
you're working leads because you didn't
work them fast you didn't work them
enough and then you get ghosted at any
part in the sales cycle just send them a
meme just send them a meme like there's
the Kevin Hart meme where he's like
where you at um and it actually has the
highest response rate out of any
messages that we've sent just sending
the meme and so uh that that Meme has
made a lot of salespeople a lot of money
and so you can just send that to your
cold pipeline send it to 200 guys uh and
you'll probably get five to 10 that just
re-engage off of that and they'll
probably laugh and then you're back in
the saddle and I'll explain why closes
die in the details when we get into the
closing section all right now the last
two pieces are actually around closing
which is is if you've sold them at this
point you've said hey does that sound
good you're ready to move forward ready
to get started ready to get some traffic
to your site ready to start losing the
weight ready to start getting back to
that High School weight whatever it is
ready to ready to insert goal that's how
you know you can ask for the sale great
let me get your ID or whatever let me
get your information start moving
forward then if they don't say yes you
explain
away concerns all right this is
fundamentally closing this is objection
handling which is the perfect thing to
get into right now now that we've
covered the open now we have to get our
money we got to close before I dive into
to the tactics one I'm going to be
bringing in audience objections so we
pulled my uh YouTube audience and said
hey what are some of the objections that
you guys are struggling with so I'm
going to be uh overcoming some of those
now live and on top of that I want to
preface with the fact that you should
train sales back to front so what do I
mean by that you want to make sure that
someone knows how to collect payment and
process as the first thing that you you
teach a closer why because if they don't
know how to do that they have a 0%
chance of closing and so the next thing
that you would teach someone is how to
ask for payment and how to ask for
someone to get started because if they
don't know how to do that the likel that
they close a sale is zero and so a lot
of people start at the top of the script
when they start teaching a closer but
it's my preference to start at the
bottom of the script because that is
what's required to close that being said
where does closing begin closing begins
once someone says no and to be very
clear just be because they said no once
doesn't mean they're saying no forever
or they're going to say no over and over
again and we have to train and expect no
that is the job of sales if every person
immediately says yes honestly you're not
really required we could just record the
video put it in front and then just put
a buy button and to be fair Tesla does
this and they they do a pretty good job
of it right and so depending on how good
you are at marketing you might not need
sales at all but under the assumption
that you're not the perfect marketer and
people come in with more questions or
more concerns when they say no is when
closers Step Up So before I get into all
the things that we can go for I want to
break down the one time where you shut
up all right which is if someone says
yes and says yes I'm in shut up and
close the sale do not sell yourself out
of a sale and this is something that a
lot of beginners do they get excited
when the person says yes and then they
start bringing up more details and then
those new details increase the
likelihood greater than zero that they
take a yes and turn it back into a maybe
or take a yes and turn into a no the
moment you have agreement you shut your
mouth you ask for payment information
and you close yeah it's like you're
you're at the bar and you're like hey
you want to go back and she's like sure
and then you're like oh yeah I'll show
you my Star Wars collection she's like
actually just kidding it's like no you
wait and then you show her the Star Wars
collection because it's sick but you
don't say it until you're back right
that's the
idea save your Lego Star Wars lightsaber
for after she gets back the next one is
that if someone says anything that you
aren't prepared for it's because you are
underprepared and so
prep equals
smooth
meaning you should in one breath know
exactly what you're going to say back to
the person when they have any kind of
objection if someone says I got to think
about it or hey you know like give me a
day or two or hey I got to talk to my
spouse or um you know I don't really
like this particular thing about the
product you should already be like take
inhaling to begin the next part of your
clothes now to be fair or to be clear
you don't want to make what you're about
to say sound like an obsolute overcome
or sound like a pre-recording and so I
made a whole video about the AAA method
which is you acknowledge then you
associate and then you move on in the
sale and you ask your next question that
is what gives the appearance of a more
natural sale meanwhile the whole time
there's nothing they can say that you
should not already know the answer to
because it is your literal job to have
this one conversation 10 times a day for
your entire life and so the fact that a
prospect can say anything that surprises
you just says that you are underprepared
that being said once we are prepped we
expect and plan for no and no is not a
failure it's to be expected so what
happens as soon as someone says I'm not
sure I need to think about it whatever
so what I want to do is give you my
rapid Fire series of questions that I
ask prior to get into anything that's
real closing all right and so the
questions that I ask are in order first
off what's your main concern all right
so if I'm early on in the sale and this
is the first no I get I'm like hey
what's your main concern because they
say I need to think about it you say
cool what's your main concern and then
you're right back in the sale it's not
like oh I need to think about it the
sale's over it's what's your main
concern let's talk about it together
let's figured it out now if you're
further on in the sale then I like to
ask a little bit harder questions so
would be like hey what are you afraid of
having happen right like dude I just
need to think about it's like dude what
are you afraid of right what do you what
do you think's going to happen what
what's the big thing that you're trying
to avoid right I ask that question
because it gets to the heart of the
issue and what you hear after that is
usually the real obstacle and that you
cannot overcome rather than I need to
think about it which you can't right and
so all of the things that uh get around
stall overcomes all basically try and
tease out why they're stalling and how
to make a decision and so from there
what's the concern what are the
variables you're using to make the
decision and my my final two that I love
very close to my heart is what makes
this a
yes what makes this a yes and if they
can't answer that question then you can
say well can I share with you some of
the the decision-making variables that I
often hear when I when I ask that
question sure now what makes this and
this is a really good one if they're
like I'm just not sure then you're like
totally understand what makes it
a and so people are so afraid to ask
what it would get someone to not buy the
thing is is that you've had this
conversation more times than them and so
sometimes they're like I you know I
don't really know you're like that's
amazing acknowledge and then we
associate it's like well it sounds like
you know believe it or not you're a
totally normal person because anybody
who'd be making a decision like this
really fast would be crazy we wouldn't
want to work with them um but it also
sounds to me like this is just that
you're nerous about making the decision
which makes you just like all the people
who end up buying and getting amazing
results and so now I Associated their
what was once I need to think about it
to I don't know what makes this a no
which then you circumvent by saying oh
it just sounds like you're afraid of
making the decision which makes you just
like other people who get amazing
results because it shows that you care
if you care you're going to follow
through and you're going to do amazing
if you don't care this is going to be
awful and so it's actually better that
you had this
fear and so now we've Associated and
then we ask the next question which is
ready to rock and roll and no like there
it's like you can even feel feel my tone
change in how I'm saying like you ready
to go ready to rock let's do this right
and so that's how I like overcoming lots
of stall uh stalls which is what you're
being concerned what are the variables
you're make using to make the decision
what would it take for this to be a yes
and what makes this a no right all great
ways of segmenting around it without
even having to get into more of the uh
standard closes
around uh I have to think about it to
give me some more time so one of the big
things that I like to train with our
team is something that I call allpurpose
closes and so allpurpose closes are the
are the
8020 um of closes so these are closes
that uh pretty much work in all
situations so you have to know price
overcomes you have to know stall
overcomes you have to know decision
maker overcomes you have to know
preference overcomes so that's when
somebody's like I don't like this
particular feature or I don't like it
that you do it this way um you to have
overcomes for all those things but the
allpurpose closes uh work in pretty much
all scenarios because all of them
basically chunk up and get yourself out
of the weed so you can just make the big
decision overall so an allp purpose
close might sound like do you think the
reason that you're on the phone today is
because you've struggled to make this
decision in the past and so that works
no matter what thing that they're
they're bringing up whether it's their
spouse it's money and you just call it
the reason so it's like oh do you think
like I think it's a lot of money say do
you think that uh the fact that you
hav't invested in the past is the reason
that you're not successful right uh I
need to talk to my spouse do you think
the reason that you haven't been
successful so far is because you've
needed to talk to your spouse for all
these things you've always needed to get
permission do you feel like the fact
that you struggled to make decisions in
the past is why you're on the phone with
me today so like it doesn't matter what
it is is whatever they say you say you
think the reason like you just take
their objection and add do you think
that's the reason that you haven't
succeeded because they haven't succeeded
yet that's the thing that you have to
your advantage they're on the phone they
have the pain and so you just say
whatever their thing is that's the
reason right now there's another one
which is just the the 1 to 10 Close
which is hey on a scale from 1 to 10 uh
10 being you know Fair let's do this one
being like let's let's never talk to
Alex again your breath stinks I hate you
uh you know where we at now it doesn't
really matter what they say you just say
after that well what would make it a 10
which is another version of like what
would it take right but just framed
differently so what would it take now if
they say a six then you can also say why
not a one and they're like well because
you're great and you're awesome and all
these things then you have them say it
not you and you're like awesome so what
would make this aent and sometimes they
just give you the one or two things like
oh I must have done a poor job of commun
that we'll totally take care of that for
you so sometimes they bring up features
that they specifically wanted or some
element that you can reframe your
existing stack and just saying oh we
satisfy that problem for you I just
didn't communicate that well are we
feeling tennish is how I like to say it
we feeling tennish awesome let's get go
let's get going right so allpurpose
closes you should know like the back of
your hand there's a bunch of other ones
I'll just leave it there otherwise the
whole rest of the video would be over
overcomes with allpurpose causes the
next one is a big big big one which is
details are death traps all right and
the reason that deals are lost in the
details is because not for what you
think the reason that details lose deals
and that they are death traps and let's
see if I can use more deal iteration is
because you don't get to pick whether
your answers are correct or not so if
someone says hey how many days a week
are you open if you answer I call that a
blind answer so it's basically you
rolling the dice that whatever you say
is the right answer which you never want
to do as a Salesman and so whenever
someone's asking a question about a
detail what I train our team to do is
ask a question about their question and
so we say oh well how many days were you
looking for or what days a week were you
do you need it to be open right because
now based on their answer I can then
hedge or frame my answer in a way that
increases the likelihood that we close
and so kind of like lawyers when they're
cross cross-examining uh you know uh
somebody on the stand they never ask
questions they already don't know the
answers to and so you as a Salesman
should never answer questions you don't
already know the answers to and if
someone really presses hard on something
this is where you appeal to the
authority of the business rather than
yourself and so you say hey totally fair
question I would say it's kind of like
asking the secretary at the heart
surgeon's place like what's wrong with
your heart without having seen the heart
surgeon yet or the alternative this is
the mechanic close which is like hey I
totally get this is super important um I
can't ethically answer your question
right now because we haven't brought
your car into the shop yet right so be
like you asking you know a mechanic hey
what's wrong with my car before you
brought it in like we got to look under
the hood before we can tell you what's
going on with it and I used to use this
whether it was hey I can't I can't tell
you what's wrong with your diet they' be
like hey well what kind of diet are you
going to be giving me I'd be like
honestly it's going to depend and so
it's going to depend on these things and
this is where you close it you say and
if anyone ever gives you an answer
before looking at that stuff run the
other way because they're just trying to
sell you stuff they're not trying to
help and so as soon as you say that you
have the moral High Ground done you're
out of the details you're out of the
weeds and you zoom out right and again a
lot of these a lot of these allpurpose
closes zoom out because people get lost
in the details they try and find
something to nitpick and every
salesman's experience knows that like
you die in the details one because it's
not your expertise two they get to tell
you what's right and so you want both of
those are terrible things that you want
to avoid and so this is where hey
sometimes you have to to say I'm be like
hey before we get deep you know deeper
in this fundamentally you want this
outcome we sell this outcome what's get
in the way here all right and where we
get into details and this is the theory
behind this that you should understand
is that a detail obstacle is actually a
preference obstacle meaning I want to
have my cake and eat it too I want your
results but I want them my way you can't
have that and so one of the ways you can
overcome this is this is specific to a a
detail CL close you say Hey you change
the variables you change the outcome I
can tell you that if you do things our
way we'll get this outcome and I also
know from what you told me earlier pain
cycle that you've tried a lot of other
ways and what you have been doing hasn't
been working for you see I'm lowering my
tone I'm seeing really reasonable right
um it hasn't been working for you and so
like if you're willing to give this a
shot I know that these are the numbers
that we can do if you follow this
process does that sound fair right and
when you say it like that you sound very
reasonable and then you can close and so
a lot of times when you get caught in
the details it's because they want
things their way and they want your
outcome and you can't have both I'd have
people say hey uh I I see this meal plan
can I just eat what I'm eating uh on the
challenge I'm like no because I was like
because eating what your eating's got in
the body that you got I was like and you
want this body which doesn't come from
that food and if you're talking to a
business owner now obviously like I have
to have poor to make that joke um but if
it's a business owner it's like no you
can't keep doing what you're doing right
you can hear my tone change no you can't
do it keep doing what you're doing
because doing what you're doing is
gotten you where you gotten right you
got to change to change right and so
that's like it always usually levels up
so you got to change to change you got
to change the got to change the
variables to change the outcome right so
don't get lost in the details and the
first response to any detail question is
asking why they care about the detail
and so you want to ask specifics about
the detail so if someone would say hey
uh you know what what certifications do
your trainers have i' be like which
certifications you looking for and
they'd be like uh I don't know it's like
right and i' be like it sounds like you
just want to make sure that you're
making inform decision what I can tell
you is right and so I was always what I
can tell you is and I I it's like it's
muscle mus memory uh what I can tell you
is is that each of my trainers are
certified in three different ways and
they're master trainers because they've
done over a thousand sessions because
I'm guessing the reason that you're
trying to ask that question is because
you want to make sure that you're safe
does that sound fair yes well let me
tell you this we haven't had a single
injury in the last two years does that
make you feel better great boom right
and so you want to Chunk Up the reason
behind the detail and so if they say hey
how many you know how many emails can I
send to your support team let's say you
had you had no emails for your support
team you'd say well one how many
questions were you looking for right and
then they're never going to be able
answer that question but even if they
did you'd say well it sounds like the
main reason that you want to again
reason the reason behind the reason that
you want that is because you just want
to make sure that you fully understand
things if you fully understood things
hypothetical if you fully understood
exactly what to do would you have
questions well no great well then if we
just make sure that you understand
exactly what you like you don't leave
the sessions with our team without
knowing exactly what you're going to do
you understand every single one of those
points that you'd feel okay great well
that's what we're going to do ready rock
and roll right and so you can you never
want to get in the details you either
question the detail or circumvent it by
trying to guess the reason behind the
detail and then chunking up and closing
that way but details are where you die
and finally of course you can mechanic
close or secretary close your way out of
it and say hey I can't ethically answer
that question because we got to bring
your car in and look under the hood
before we can actually give you an
honest answer and it's going to depend
so the next one is the AAA system now I
made an entire training on this because
it's so important but I'm just G to give
you the high level on it which is
whenever someone asks you uh a question
or they give you some sort of objection
you want to follow the Tria framework
and I realized this only years into
teaching sales that this is what
separated my top salespeople from my
mediocre sales people and they did it
naturally and I never caught it which is
that they first
acknowledge what the person said so the
reason you do this is twofold one is
because it buys you time to think about
what you're going to say next because uh
they say something you repeat it back to
them it's like oh so it sounds like
right it's you basically say the last
phrase back to them so it buys you time
and when someone hears you rephrase what
they just said it builds Rapport because
it looks like you're actively listening
which you should be and so one you keep
Rapport and you give yourself a little
bit of time a little bit of breathing
room then you
associate what they said with either
something positive which is like hey
that's a smart question or that's
amazing or uh totally understandable
like those are just I would say generic
neutral associations or you make an
association with someone that you just
talked to earlier that day somebody who
used the product and loved it and got
amazing success or some Authority in the
business who gave you Insight that they
don't know so it's like that's an
amazing question I actually just talked
to our senior engineer earlier today and
he actually told me this can I share it
with you right that allows you to sell a
harsh truth to somebody without actually
attacking their character and so if
someone says something uh that's way off
I'd be like totally understand where
you're coming from uh I think it's a
super fair question do you mind if I uh
share something that I talked to someone
earlier this morning had the same issue
as you and it helped them get over it
now again I'm not now saying this to you
I'm telling you what I told them and I
just happen to be telling you so I'm not
insulting you I'm telling you my harsher
truth that I told this person and then
you can connect the dots and so by
having those associations it creates
foils for people's egos so you can have
more direct conversation indirectly and
then the last part is obviously just ask
so you acknowledge you associate then
you ask the next question and that's how
you move forward in the sale because
this is a law that you must understand
about
closing key
who
asks the
most
times
gets the
most
sales this is a law he who asks the most
times gets the most sales and the reason
that this is so important is because
asking when you ask wrong usually loses
you sales and because they don't want to
talk to you anymore and so if they get
into a bad mood they don't buy and so
how do you reconcile asking a lot of
times closing the most sales with when
you ask wrong people stop wanting to
talk to you therefore you can't ask more
times what Bridges this Rapport and so
the reason this is so important is
because it gives you unlimited shots on
goal you stay in the saddle you stay in
the sale rather than getting knocked off
and you can tell when someone's complete
demeanor changes they close off you've
already lost the sale right you lost
them you lost Rapport and so by ackn
ning what they say associating with
something positive or someone positive
someone like them who got this big
result it allows you to say harsher
overcomes that allow you to move the
sale forward two three steps rather than
just kind of like for lack of a better
term footing around it and so this
is what allows the best sales people to
ask hard truths because closers ask hard
questions so In The Same Spirit as this
in order to keep this whole tone I like
to remind my team childlike curiosity
and the point of this is that you want
to understand not win and so if someone
doesn't immediately buy it should be
your first instinct to not be like screw
this person I'm going to hard close them
because it probably won't work instead
being like huh that's interesting I
wouldn't have expected that can you tell
me more about that or hey so all of
these things are different ways of
acknowledging and so I even taught this
to uh our team and I you can even see it
with my head when I say huh I always
tilt my head up because that's how I
naturally am curious and so when someone
does this you're not like oh this guy's
going to try and be combative with me
it's like huh that's interesting and so
that one buys you more time it also
isn't competitive it's not you attacking
them it's you not trying to prove them
wrong because if you prove them wrong
you make no money so you want to be
right not rich the classic ISM you
become rich by making them right because
they believe nothing about what you say
they believe everything about what they
say and so the reason that sales people
ask questions because we need them to
say it not us so within that context
because closers ask hard questions and
because we are curious that means that
we ask more questions and so what a lot
of people don't know is the person
asking is the person
closing so there's a reason that when
you're in an interrogation they're like
I'm asking the questions here it's
because the person asking the questions
is the one who's in control you're the
one who's leading the sale because the
questions guide the conversation the
answers do not
and so you want to be the the spirit
guide who's letting your questions guide
the person to the Natural conclusion and
so fundamentally sales is an education
process and so our goal is to Simply
figure out what pieces of information
they need in order to make a decision
and act on it and so if we think about
sales as teaching because teaching is
same conditions new Behavior then we
want them to now have a new Behavior
which is buying which we've motivated
them to do by pointing out the
deprivation they've had in their lives
and presenting our solution as the thing
that will Bridge that Gap and so if
someone asks you questions it's like hot
potato that's why we ask a question back
because we Take Back Control the reason
the details are death is because they
are asking you questions they are in
control not you the other reason that
questions are so powerful is that no one
can disagree with a question all right
so it doesn't matter what what they say
if you just ask a question about it
there's they can't disagree with the
question question which makes you like
smoke and so this is my little ISM that
I like telling my team is that you want
to be like smoke like they can't catch
you like any any statement that you give
is an opportunity for them to disagree
and we want to never disagree with
prospects now some people might disagree
with that and I don't care uh and so the
thing is is you don't disagree with
prospects because the likely that you
lose Report with the prospect super high
you can agree with the reason behind the
question you can agree or say that it's
understandable for them to have a
question
but you don't want to disagree so
there's very different saying don't
disagree with agreeing with everything
they say very different you just don't
want to create a competitive environment
and so questions allow you to have that
Gap and so statements are bombs that
they can then blow up in your face and
so if we are ever going to answer things
we check to see what answer they want
and then say it and so they say hey what
kind of food's on the plan I say what
kind of food you looking for hey what
are your workouts like well what
workouts you looking for right like and
then they say well I was hoping you do
some sort of cardan Weights well that's
exactly what you do you're in luck right
because they just told me the answer and
so it's amazing at the end of this
they're like dude this sounds exactly
like what I want I'm like yes because
you told me what you wanted and I told
you that's what it was now again you
want to be ethical and making sure that
you're not deceiving people but I think
it's way more about how you frame the
solution right if I say hey what kind of
workouts you looking for and they say uh
I want to do a lot of cardio and if I
know that there's no cardio in our thing
for example I might be like why and
they'd be like uh well I heard that
that's what I need to lose weight and
I'm like what if we could help you lose
weight and you wouldn't have to do card
you would still want to do it and then
they probably like well yeah and be like
awesome well let's focus on that because
this is what I can help you do do you
care a lot about how we get there and a
lot of times most people are like no as
long as you get me there and so this
again Loops us out it gets you into you
want cake you also want to eat it let me
just get you cake and then we can I
don't know what you do with cake if
you're not eating it but that's where
that
and then we can throw it there we go all
right so even though
we're point being is that you either
question questions or you ask the right
answer from the person before answering
it and so if you think about this as the
decision trait someone ask a detail
question you then ask a question what's
the right answer to this question they
then tell you the right answer if you
have the right answer you say great
that's what we have if they if you don't
have that as the right answer you ask
why they have that and then you chunk up
to the reason behind it and then say if
we got to that same solution either way
would you care about how we got there
both of those note got you out of the
details and you never answered a
question you didn't already know the
answer to as we're going through these
closing things right rather than make
this an entire thing of just obstacle
overcomes um I I really want to tease up
to the the the strategy behind this
rather than just heav you know shout
lines at you all right and so we talk
about killing zombies early another way
of thinking about is like you want to
diffuse the bomb before you get into the
cloth um and the reason that we do
zombies is because if zombies get close
to you they eat you and they bite you
right so you want to kill them from a
distance before they get close all right
and so you handle zombies earlier on in
the sale and so if you recall from bant
these are typically going to be your
zombies right budget Authority need
timing hey is there anyone else that
needs to uh be on the call or involved
in this decision hey uh just to be clear
the reason that we do the labeling up
front that gives us the need right
timing like are you good to start now
when would you like to start if we were
to move forward right budget some of
these things you can ask in the
application you can ask them the
qualifier but when you ask them in the
pain cycle for example and this is where
you can actually collect all your gold
for this is when you ask what they've
done in the past you can get an idea of
what their need was what the timing was
what the budget was hey was your husband
involved in that decision right and so
you can collect all the data you need
around B before getting to the close and
so if you consistently have a few things
that come up in the close and blow up in
you then you want to just load those
earlier in the sale before you ask for
money because anything that you ask for
after making money is when you're in the
very very uh tight RPP area if if you're
asking to overcome those things before
money there's no Stakes on the table yet
I like to tell my team literally in
person you always want to be on the same
side of the table if you're via Zoom or
phone you want to figuratively be on the
same side of the table they want to feel
like you're an ally you you going to be
shoulder Tosh shoulder you be across the
corner of the table not across the table
overall and so when you're in the
beginning of the sale you want to be a
FactFinder you want to be a guide right
if you're positioned as a helpful guide
throughout this whole process then you'd
asking these questions are things that
are going to help you help them if
you're asking them after you've asked
for money it's a way for you to extract
money from them and so it shifts the
frame when you ask these questions and
these are all answerable prior to asking
for money another one is just a little
ISM which is a when in doubt repeat it
back or one in doubt say it back uh and
that's because if you're like Oh shoot
what am I going to say you can just
always just pause be like so you want to
know which certifications our trainers
have and they're just going to look at
you like yes okay I was just thinking
about the stuff that we have which ones
are you looking for specifically right
and so that gives you that time to to
come up with whatever your answer so if
you get into into ghost mode you can
always just slowly say back what they
just asked you and you'll still stay in
the sale and keep report rather than
having a long awkward silence so when in
doubt say it
back all right so the next one is
before
getting
real get
permission so I would say that this
depends on your frame within the sale
and so if you're seen as an authority
then you can say hey can I be a coach
instead of a friend here hey can I put
my uh can I put my real hat on hey do
you mind if I get real with you for a
second before before we move on so these
are all ways to uh gain permission
before giving someone a harsh truth now
if you're in a sale let's say you're a
20-year- old guy and you're closing you
know 40-year-old business owners that
are doing $20 million a year that's
probably not going to work right and so
that's where the other three foils that
I brought up in the associate part of
that sounds like somebody else just like
you because now it's using the authority
of somebody else like them which is
their own authority uh using again
Someone Like You Who Saw success it's
just a different version or if there's
an authority in the business or the
product that you can lean on so hey our
senior engineer oh our founder those are
things that as long as your founder
which presumably if they're coming to
the business you Le they have some
Authority if they're thinking about
working with you um then that gives you
some Authority that the salesman can
then transfer in giving a hard truth um
and so but this that's the common
language before you're going to say
something harsh if you ever heard a
close or read a close and be like dude I
don't think I could say that it's
usually because you didn't triaa
beforehand right you didn't acknowledge
what they said associate with what they
said reframe it uh and then ask the
question with some sort of like can I be
a coach and said of a friend here uh or
would it be totally overstepping for me
to uh share this harsh truth with you
and I say not harsh truth so be like
that thing hey would it be totally
overstepping um if I shared something
with you that might be uncomfortable uh
right um can I tell you what I told
somebody in your exact same position
right now that's that's an example of
the foil Association rather than the
first two if I'm selling consumer weight
loss you can get away with the first two
if someone's coming to you for weight
loss coaching you can say can I be a
coach inside of a friend it makes sense
you're starting that relationship if
you're just a Salesman stick with the
foils that I was mentioned earlier next
one is uh learn to stack closes all
right so something that you'll notice or
at least me in my my career um selling
is that some it's like it's sometimes
they're like on the fence they're on the
edge and they're like teetering that's
where you want to like right hook jab
jab ja like you want to just like ah and
then and push them over um so I don't I
don't know if I subscribe to the uh
whoever talks first after you uh mention
money like money maybe but um I can tell
you I've closed plenty of sales where
like I could like hey seems like you're
hesitating right let me like let's let's
let's close this up more um but in the
vast majority now obviously with a price
drop uh sometimes you do want to wait
but the vast majority of other times
when I have a big pause I'll just insert
more closes from different angles around
the same uh obstacle so if someone's
saying hey for example I don't have a
lot of time right now then I'm going to
know one I'll Attack on the fact that
hey the first thing we're going to do is
cut out 90% of the stuff that you that's
not working because that's why you're
here so that you will be spending your
time doing the stuff that matters I also
know be like hey at the end of the day
this is a question of priori it's not
time right because everybody has it and
there's other people in your industry
who are growing faster than you and they
have the same resources so we just need
to allocate them differently right um
and then I could go from a a macro busy
perspective which is well I understand
that you're totally busy I think it's
really reasonable that that you say that
um so let me ask you a question do you
think that you ever going to be not busy
again in the future this is a trap
they're going to say yes and say cool do
you ever think you'll be busy again in
the the future and now they're like well
yeah it's like okay well if you can't
succeed when you're busy then it means
that you'll fall off when you're busy
again and so if you want this to be
permanent then we have to figure out how
to make it work during all seasons does
that sound fair does that make sense got
it and so now it's like I just had three
different ways and so whichever one I
said first if they're like still
thinking about it I like if I just said
the seasons one I'd be like hey and no
matter what we're going to cut out 90%
of the stuff that you're doing right now
so we're going to save you that time so
you can start doing the stuff that
matters right because it's going to be
ities not how much time you got right
everybody's got the same amount of time
right okay cool right and so I just went
three closes in a row after as the after
making the first one and so learning how
to stack closes and weave them together
will make all your closing more
effective and this is why knowing the
theory behind the close is more
important than trying to memorize what
close it is which kind of brings me to
this um the next one is I think there's
a lot of guys who say to memorize closes
I couldn't even tell you uh I don't
think I've really hard poor memorized
any clo I know the gist of almost all of
them word for word not really uh
so don't don't
memorize understand and so let me walk
you through the big understandings that
you have to have all right so if someone
comes with a Time objection they're too
busy then it's really understanding
that's a prioritization thing that's all
it is so we have to allocate the
resources differently that's all the
closes that are going to be around time
are going to be around that
a decision maker close is going to be
around you want support not permission
right so they're going to ask for
permission you're going to try and
empower the person saying hey we're
going to rely on past behaviors this
person has said we're going to fact find
to say oh you know what it turns out
they've done all these other things that
would indicate that they're already okay
with you making this decision and so I
think you want to go for support not
permission it's better to ask for
forgiveness than permission ha right and
so you can make those make those little
isms but all of those are going to
circle around that that main thing if
someone's saying details it's going to
be preferences it's going to say want
your thing my way and so we need to
overcome the fact that if they change
the variables they change the outcome uh
and all the closes around details are
more or less going to be around
basically that fundamental line of
reasoning um if someone says money then
you're going to basically zero in on
value because nothing is ever too
expensive it's just not worth it right
if I was giving you a Ferrari for five
grand you would find a way to come up
with five grand of course which then
leads to the second underlying one which
is about resourcefulness not resource
ources because if you really thought
that this was going to be the thing that
was going to change your life you'd find
a way to make it work right if I were
giving you the keys to my Ferrari for
five grand you would call 10 friends and
get the money together which means
fundamentally you don't see the value
and so every one of the obstacles that
people will throw at you you just need
to understand the fundamental fallacy of
belief that they're presenting with so
that you can help overcome it and stall
overcomes the last kind of category are
stalls link back to decision avoidance
so it's typically either fear uh of
making the wrong decision which we
reassure them that is the right decision
and not knowing how to make a decision
so then we walk them through how to make
a logical decision what questions they
should ask and we just lead them through
it that's it and when I go through the
uh objections that my audience came up
with um whatever I respond with I'm not
saying say word for word I think
understanding the argument behind it is
what will help you close more deals in
that same vein you really only need to
have two to three closes per obstacle
that you really like all right and so
that's why I'm saying like you don't
have to memorize them but you would you
would want to know the two or three that
you're usually going to bring up when it
comes to uh a Time overcome or a money
overcome or a decisionmaker overcome or
a stall close uh or an avoidance thing
right all of those are you just want to
have two to three that you know like I
could give you a hundred but which one
you're going to use on a regular basis
it's going to depend on the ones that
you feel most comfortable saying in your
own language in the spirit of the
allpurpose closes
uh earlier I said when in doubt say it
back another thing is that if you ever
get lost in the details or you're just
like you're like where am I right now
lost question
zoom out all right so this is where you
say whoa whoa tot okay I feel like we've
got we've got all the way to Pluto uh
and back together so big picture right
this is how it you always phrase it like
big picture or let's zoom out for a
second this is where we say hey best
case worst case right this is an
allpurpose close so it's zoom out out
best case worst case best case we get
you this thing worst case you get six
weeks of free service from us and you
get your money back if you hate us all
right and so again getting best case
worst case closes um especially strong
if you have any kind of guarantee um
that's associated with whatever it is
that you sell hugely valuable mostly
just because best Cas worth Cas clothes
just murders because you can say listen
at the end of the day you have two
options both are risk-free you canot do
this go home and that's guarant aned to
get you in the exact same position
you're currently at or you can take a
shot here also risk-free but you've got
a chance of getting what you want so one
is guaranteed to not the other one's got
a chance both are risk-free which one
you want right best case worst case and
so guarantees help you boil the decision
down so low that it's just simple yes no
and so uh whenever you're lost zoom out
so finally you have reinforced the
decision so you're like wait a second
where is that coming from so the closer
frame has c l o s e r so everything I've
talked about has been e which is explain
away their concerns the last step of all
of these is that you want to reinforce
the decision all right and so when you
reinforce the decision it's actually
what happens after you've gotten the
money so you've explained explained away
their concerns they now buy and then
post swipe post purchase that's when you
do the handshake all right now I'm not
saying a physical handshake I'm saying
that you pass them off instead of a hand
off you do a handshake with customer
success so if you've ever seen you know
from this whole you know video so far
there's the through line that all
information should get passed like a
baton from the person to the next person
in line and so I like using this concept
of bamfam which is book a meeting from a
meeting and every interaction with a
customer they should know exactly when
the next time they're going to be
meeting and with whom and the with whom
person should know all of the
conversation they've had up to that
point so they know a lot about the
Prospect and what the salespeople have
said up to that point so that they know
the goals the aspirations the fears the
pains so that when they talk to them
they can talk in those terms and it will
be unbelievably more compelling now
we've we implemented this one of our
portfol companies I made a case study
about it just switching from a handoff
to a handshake handoff is like good luck
right and they pass him to the Cs team
and the Cs team is like oh I'm trying to
catch it right rather than John this is
Sarah Sarah's going to help you with
your XYZ problem so that you can
accomplish goal and she's going to walk
you through with the next steps look
like you know it's been a pleasure
talking to you she's going to take care
of you she's cured cancer six times and
someone said she walked on water once I
can't confirm it but she's amazing Sarah
gets on and says John we're gon she's
we're going to help you take care of
this thing and the way we're going to do
that is then lays out the proof promise
plan but specific and personalized to
the pains and the and the and the
aspirations of the Prospect and so we
want to reinforce the decision because
this video is about making more sales
and just about that is about keeping
more sales and so if you reinforce the
decision you'll get a lot fewer drop
offs back outs cold feet first 30-day
refunds things like that all right so
now let's get into FAQs from the
audience and so these are going to be
real examples of real objections that
you guys are getting that I'm going to
do my very best uh to help
overcome so the first one we got is a
cheap competitor so the good news for
you is that we have one that we
literally just call the cheap competitor
close so uh this one you can smash so
you just say hey um if ours was the same
as theirs which one would you do then
they're going to say well I would do
yours and you're like why and then
they'll say well you have this thing
that seems a little better you got this
thing my friend referred to you you're
like right that's why we're more so you
let them tell you all the things that
make you better rather than you telling
them what makes you better and then you
say yeah and the thing is is usually
when you say it like that most people
laugh like you're like right and that's
why we're like and that's why we're
we're more right because we're better
and you know it that's why you're here
also by the way that's usually a uh it's
usually a buying question so that's good
it means you're pretty close to the sale
so that's called the cheap comparison
close all right so the next one you guys
had was uh the ID close because I do
this in person so if you don't know what
the ID close is is that I prefer to
close sales rather than asking for form
of payment when I'm in person for asking
for their ID first the reason I do that
is because someone takes their wallet
out usually they put it on the table or
they take their purse out and they pull
out their wallet that has all their
cards in it and so when they do that a
lot of little things can't happen after
that point they can't say forgot their
uh wallet they can't say they forgot
their credit card at home because now
it's right in front of me right and
because I didn't ask for their payment
yet I asked for their ID and so we asked
for the ID and I also like to do this
because when I get it there's always a
little bit of chitchat that happens
there so I'm like oh you should see my
picture it's terrible oh so you're from
you know blah blah blah oh that's
amazing you know I got a friend who's
out there and you're filling out and
also make sure that you fill out all the
information correctly which one of the
one of the ways that you can lose a sale
is that you put the wrong payment
information in or you tie to the wrong
uh uh ZIP code and you're like oh by the
way this how you can lean into like the
ZIP code that you have for this is this
the same zip that you have for the form
payment you want to use right and at
that point then you say awesome you put
it between your fingers and you gesture
towards the wallet wherever it is on the
table say I'll trade you for whatever
one you want to use right and so it's
cute it's easy you trade like this but
it's clear your line of sight it's like
they can't say now this just eliminates
a lot of BS so that you don't have to oh
I forgot my it's like well I didn't ask
for that yet and so if you're on Zoom so
that's what this is about how do I do
that same close you just say awesome can
you put your ID next to the camera is to
make sure that we associate the right
account profile with the right payment
and this to make sure that you're you
listen nowadays we just try to be
careful we try to be PCI Compliant I
just made that up it doesn't matter the
point is like I asked you and like if
you're really not true you just say
that's how we've always done it they'll
be fine with it don't worry about it all
right the next one uh is just generic uh
decision maker which is I have to talk
to my spouse my dog my grandmother my
business partner my emotional partner
partner whatever right fundamentally
they're saying that they don't have the
authority to make the decision and so
first off if you know that whatever you
sell is something that will materially
affect a business or household then you
want to give the opportunity for them to
talk to their spouse in the setting
process right and so either it's uh you
either bring both of them on the call uh
if you're like selling B2B or you're
selling B Toc uh so especially like I
have a friend of mine who sells really
high ticket weight loss stuff they ask
the partner uh to get on the phone this
is specifically women and then they end
up just closing both Partners they're
like ah you know you should join to and
then they sell they make two sales out
of it they sell the husband and the wife
because you get better results when you
do together cool it turns the negative
into another sale opportunity if you're
in a business situation having the
business partners on the phone
beforehand helps now I also understand
that there are times when it's like
you've got one shot and this is your
this is your opportunity so I follow
process which is number one I say what
would happen if they said no and if I'm
talking to a more egotistical guy I
would say what happens if they don't
give you
permission because it makes them sound
like a uh and so by doing that
they're like oh I don't need permission
then you're like awesome let's get you
taken care of then right done over it
now this is very crazy but one out of
three times when you say what would
happen if they said no they're like I'd
do it anyways you're like so what are we
waiting for let's get started now the
two out of three times they'll say
something like well then I wouldn't do
it now some people say oh now that's
where that sale ends no we got tons
of questions left so you say oh well
what do you think would be their main
concern so now all I'm doing is just
shifting from okay okay you're not the
decision maker now let's talk to this
hypothetical person they've used their
partner as a foil the same way we use
this hypothetical person we talked to
earlier today as a foil for what they
want it works the same way it's just in
reverse and so you say so what's their
main concern even though they have no
idea and haven't been in the
conversation then what they're going to
do is they're going to tell you what
their main concern is through the mouth
of this hypothetical person they've made
as their business partner and then you
can actually follow through the same
well what would you think would make
them say no what do you think would make
an absolute yes for them what would it
take for us to move forward right and so
those are trying to isolate variables
and if you can offshoot there into
whatever that person says would be the
issue then you're out of the decision
maker frame and now you're closing the
obstacle now if they still say you know
they would be concerned with this or
that or whatever then I rotate into um
past agreements all right so past
agreements is like huh well do you think
uh like what would you think would be a
good indication that they would be okay
with it like from the stuff that you've
done already like do they know that
you're here do they know that like have
you bought things like this in the past
do they know that you're in pain with
the situation right now yes well if they
don't approve of your current situation
why would they not approve of you
solving something they already don't
approve of right so it's taking a
reversing a negative and so here it's
like sometimes you'll get they'll be
like you know you're right I think
that's fine if you still can't close
then you resort to support not
permission right and that's kind of like
the final kind of final straw but I try
and offshoot I really focus a lot on
that trying to break the foil and say
what do you think their main concern is
make it a no for them because now we're
isolating issues and we can tackle them
rather than getting around decision
maker but if they insist on decision
maker and you insist on having to close
the sale right now then you go to hey I
think that you're asking for permission
when you really should be looking for
support right because at the end of the
day if we play this out let's say your
business doesn't grow uh like who are
you going to blame is it fair to the
partnership that you don't get this
outcome because you rely on this person
person no right because all this is
going to do is that if you to not get
this person's
permission 5 years down the road where
you going to be right and who you going
to blame because fundamentally if
they're the one who are in charge then
they're the ones who also get all the
blame which means that you're not in any
way control of your own life and I don't
think that's fair to you I don't think
it's fair to them I don't think it's for
the
relationship and so that's the support
not permission angle and so that gives
you a lot of offshoots to uh close prior
to getting to that the decision maker is
the hardest one to overcome of all cloes
is because it's the only one that the
person says I can't make a decision so
doesn't matter what you say I have no
Authority and so the whole point like
the reasoning behind this is you see if
they actually do have authority and
they're just using it as a smoke screen
that's like the one out of three right
off the bat they say why I would do it
anyways that's a smoke screen done you
already closed the deal if they're using
it because they don't want to say what
their actually what their real objection
is then they're using this person to
tell you a hard truth because they're
afraid of insulting you because you know
it goes both ways and so then you say oh
well what would the you know what do you
think they would be afraid of having
happen What like um what would make them
say no and then you can overcome that
because it actually wasn't really that
they don't have decision-making
Authority they just didn't want to say
this thing but if they truly don't have
decision-making Authority trying to then
relate the fact that it's like oh you
might not have authority but they have
already agreed with you based on their
past agreements and so if you think
about each of these as arguments number
one is you do you actually have
authority and don't care uh
two is you were afraid to tell me and
have authority the third is you don't
have authority but they already have
agreed based on what they've already
done and then the fourth is basically
trying to get them to take authority of
their own lives by asking for support
not permission so that's the reasoning
behind kind of that four-step close with
that has offshoots all the way through
but if someone's like I absolutely need
must that's why we try to no matter what
if we know that this is a common thing
or it's an expensive you know if you're
trying to sell houses you're not going
to close the close the spouse and buying
the house without the other spouse it's
not going to happen right and so if you
know that both people are going to be
required for whatever it is that you
sell just involve them in the process
earlier so let's say someone says hey
everything sounds amazing uh give me
some time so it's actually there's like
there's a false truth in there that's
embedded which is it's actually not good
enough here's why so if someone says hey
you know this sounds amazing let me
Circle back in a couple quarters you say
awesome so what are you going to be
doing
instead and so then they're going to say
X Y and Z and then you're like okay um
zooming out and hey if you don't this is
just a question I asked somebody earlier
today and they it they said it was
enlightening so you mind if I share it
with you right because I'm already
getting into hard territory here right
so U at that point I'd say do you think
that doing what this is is going to get
you better returns than what we're
talking about right because again time
is priorities so all like fundamentally
like I said earlier like you have to
understand the theory behind this
they're saying I have other things that
are more important and so we have to say
no this is more important which means we
have to elevate the value of what we're
currently doing or devalue what they're
currently doing so fundamentally that's
the that's how we're attacking this so
it's like what are you going to do
instead got it do you think it'll make
you more than this and if they say yes
then you'd say why if they say no then
it's like oh then you should prioritize
this let's get rolling right and so with
each of these you'll not there's like
there's offshoots like if if they say
yes then it's done you've already closed
it right if they say uh no I think this
other thing would make me more money and
the thing is is if there right then they
should do
that and so a big part of being an
ethical salesman is that the moment that
you feel like a prospect is better
served not doing something you should
stop but this is why you want to sell
stuff that works better right uh but if
you do have something that you know will
make the more money then all you have to
do is break down how it's going to make
them more money and then cover cost of
in action so that would be okay so uh
let's put math to it and that's how I'd
say like let's put some math let's let's
put some numbers down so if we improve
your conversion rate you know by 30%
that would increase Revenue by 30% but
you have uh you know gross margins of 90
and so and your and your current net
margins are 30 and so if we do that
we'll actually double the profit of the
business so the things that you're
working on right now um are those
doubling the profit of the business and
over what time period over two quarters
well if we could double the profit of
the business would that allow you to
make those things happen even faster
okay just asking so I can understand
right and so again when you're getting
into those situations it's always the
seek to understand frame right that's
the that's where we're coming from and
so if you have elevated yourself to a
helpful guide then it shouldn't feel
combative it's like totally get it just
so I'm clear you're saying that because
the stuff that you're going to do is
make you more money than what we're
talking about and if they're like no
then it's like oh then why are you
prioritizing
it right and the thing is a lot of times
whenever someone gives you an answer you
can always ask why because then you can
go chunk up to reason and then basically
say oh my thing actually solves that
reason even better so uh I'm really busy
right now is different from the give me
some time and it sounds similar but
they're actually different uh different
objections right which is I don't have
time I'm busy right now whatever all
right so this one is give me some time
to make the decision like let me decide
in a week that's when you go that's
avoidance that's decision avoidance if
someone says I don't have time and I
could do this later that's the I'm busy
which means that we're we're talking
about priorities what else are you doing
that's more important than this so let's
say that you don't have a guarantee
which is fine I don't have a guarantee
around most of the things that I sawell
all right um the anti-g guarantee is how
I like to sell around guarantee which is
oh if you're the type of person who
needs a guarantee then this is
definitely not for you because at the
end of the day we can control we can
control we can't control what you do so
do you think it'd be fair for us to
guarantee work I have no input in doing
and so it really just comes down to
basically the more control you have the
more you can offer a guarantee the less
control you have the less you can offer
a guarantee if you choose not to offer
them and so you want to basically do a
takeaway sale on the guarantee being
like oh this is really for people who
are serious about doing it are you
serious about doing it okay cool I can't
control I can't eat the food for you I
can't work out for you I can give you
the guide and I can tell you that
hundreds of other people have S
succeeded but I can't do it for you
myself it's one of the few things that I
can't do right does that sound
reasonable right and that's and that's
where like reasonable is what we're
going with is that sound fair so that
makes sense uh around an anti-g
guarantee for uh for not having a
guarantee if they off if they say you
don't have one all right so the next one
that came from the audience was uh hey
let me watch some of your free stuff or
let me go through your lead magnet right
so like if you've got some sort of
resources that you put out there and
then they get on the sales call and say
oh well you know or this sales call was
super helpful I think I'm just going to
you know do the stuff that you said on
the sales call what you do is you agree
with them and say oh absolutely you
should do that uh and do that before you
come out or before you start our program
or before you whatever before we start
and kick you off so you just say you
should totally do that because if you do
that successfully then one of two things
is going to happen either you're going
to succeed in which case you're going to
run into another problem that I can help
you solve or you're not going to succeed
in which case I can help you solve it to
begin with but either way you should you
should get started so let's get you
moving and so again we have to take it
from I want to do this thing we agree
with them we're not disagreeing you
should totally do that stuff because it
will make you money and one of two
things are going to happen you're going
to succeed in which case you're going to
run into another issue which we can help
you solve
or you're not going to succeed in which
case we can help you solve
that either way results in you doing it
so let's get started if you sell to the
government or you have very large
Enterprises that require 6 12 month
sales cycles and you need multiple
stakeholders uh to buy in much of the
stuff that I covered here is not going
to apply and that's because these are
these are transactional these are
basically these fundamentally all of
these force a prospect to make a
decision now in a big Fortune 100 or a
government sale things like that
oftentimes no one has the ability to
make a decision and it's a decision by
committee and so you basically need to
continue to stay in the pocket and in
most Enterprise sales the amount of
people that the customer talks to in
your organization increases the
likelihood of closing and a smooth uh
transition and so if they talk to two or
three people on your team and you talk
to two or three people on their team
it's like uh I'll give you a
visual so if it's you and one person
this Bond easily broken but if it's
you and three people on their team and
two people on
yours then you
have uh uh whatever I could draw all
these connections but you get the you
get the you get the point there you go
so there's way more ties and this is
much harder to break and so with
Enterprise sales it looks more like this
than it does like this so hopefully feel
like I helped you guys overcome some of
the obstacles that you brought up
otherwise we could be here all day now
that we forget out closing we just got
to make sure that our heads space is
right and we continue to do the right
things over and over again so wrap up
with mindset now I hate the term mindset
overall because I'm like what does that
even mean and so what I'm going to try
and do is reframe some set things that I
have into behaviors that they apply to
all right so sales mindset number one
the person who cares the most about the
prospect wins the sale and so if they
care more about themselves than you care
about them they will win and so in terms
of what does this change about your
behavior the idea is that if you truly
care about them you will usually not
lose Rapport in the sale because you
will always seek to understand and so
then you will always your tone will
change your conviction will change
because because fundamentally it says
keep the human first if this is no
longer a good idea for them you should
not sell them you should tell them I
think it's a good idea for you not to do
this and I promise you there's nothing
more powerful than learning to turn away
prospects which will increase your
overall closing percentage because you
will know that you are in this to help
people make decisions to help themselves
and so if you try to close everybody you
will it will start to wear on you over
time because you'll know that you're a
piece of all right and so either
you're you become a sociopath or you
your sales will go down so instead make
sure you qualify prospects Never Lie um
and if you keep the person at the center
of the sale then when someone says I got
to think about it you're
like Sarah I'm trying to figure out how
to make this work for you because I know
this is going to help you and I I want
to help you make this decision because I
I just genuinely believe that so what
are the what's what are you most afraid
of right now like what are you what are
you afraid of having happen right and
then you get to the heart of it and the
thing is is if you keep that Rapport you
will close more sales because they will
feel that you do care so the next one
comes from uh my team so this is one
that I repeat over and over and over
again so this is banged into their
skulls uh volume negates luck all right
and so the big thing uh with sales is
that it is a num game it's like dating
you just have to know what the pipeline
is and the guys who become the best
salespeople are the ones who do the most
volume volume and so there's this
relationship between volume and skill
the more you do the better you get the
better you get the more you do and so
the idea is that you want to in the
beginning force feed yourself through
tons and tons of volumes so that you can
get through the terrible period as fast
as possible because a master in any
domain has more ways to reward
themselves if you're a master editor
then when you look at a video there's a
hundred things that you can do that you
know how to do that you enjoy doing that
you've been rewarded in the past for
doing if you're a Salesman who's a
master salesman you can you like pulling
a sale out of the depths you love
overcoming the details you enjoy being
in the red zone and kind of navigating
those conversations because it's a fun
challenge for you when you're a beginner
you're freaked out and you're paranoid
you don't know what you're doing and so
the idea is to you to follow what Kobe
Bryant did so if everybody else is
working out once a day if I work out
three times a day I'm going to get
better that much faster and so my
recommendation is find the person on
your team who's the best closer and do
double the effort that they're doing and
if you're like dude that's barely even
possible great welcome to getting better
right and the thing is is that I'll I'll
draw this this visual that uh that we we
introduce a lot of our our sales team
with which is this is what your skill is
going to look like over
time so this is this might take you know
two to three months and this might take
you know a year and this might take you
know two to three years
for your skill so this is my skill here
we go but what people don't understand
is that this is your
income and so in the beginning you just
learn not to suck which is fantastic and
very important to suck less but
eventually you'll suck so little that
you'll actually be very good and all of
the best returns in life come at the
very end of Mastery and so people give
up in this period of
time but they miss out this much where
all of the gains are going to happen
because they quit early and so you have
to approach sales as a skill and if you
hate it just understand it's not that
you hate it because you somehow have
some natural distaste for
sales you just aren't skilled enough
because I promise the best salespeople
love selling the best editors love
editing the best writers love writing
and when the best editor started editing
they sucked at editing and the best
sales people started sales they sucked
at sales I didn't close my first sale
all right I'm just saying like but I had
enough reward cycles and I forced enough
volume down my throat that I started
liking it and then once you like it that
reward Cycle takes over all right the
next one is sales resumés don't matter
and I'm gonna I'm gonna I'm GNA explain
what I mean by this so I have had two
times in my career where our sales teams
were not growing at the rate that they
needed to to support the amount of
demand that was coming in and that was
very frustrating for me and once I dove
in I wrote a chapter about this in uh my
leads book on the uh employees chapter
um once I dove in I found out that in
both situations they were screening
heavily the salespeople's resumee to
qualify them to get interviewed and that
is typically in my opinion a mistake
because especially in a transactional
selling environment so if you're
thinking setting or one to two call
closing so very short sales Cycles
you're going to immediately look for
other skills outside of what their past
experience is that you can tell very
quickly on a call and so I am more
Pro Group interviews and so you can just
invite everyone onto the call and
quickly do one to two minute interviews
with everyone who hops on because the
star salespeople will in that
environment where they need to speak up
be more assertive be more social uh one
they'll speak up two they'll be clear
communicators three the really good ones
uh will also encourage other people who
are nervous so that's just something
that we've noticed there they're going
to be more team players at least the
type of salesp people that we want to
attract and so group interviews instead
of resume screening as one of the
easiest ways to scale a sales team that
we've found now one of the things that
people don't understand about this is
the understanding between
attitude and aptitude all right so
you've probably heard the like hi for
attitude uh not for aptitude all right
so that is true sort of and so let me
explain so so fundamentally the real
truth is you should always hire for the
lowest skill deficiency so it's just
what are the deficient skills what is
the cost of training these skills I want
to hire people who have the lowest
efficiency which means that I have the
fastest ramp up or the highest return on
investment for them becoming proficient
in the business that's fundamentally
what all hiring is in general not just
sales and so the thing is is that we
have these bundled terms like kind
hardworking right uh
uh uh charismatic whatever right but the
thing is is that these are bundled terms
that actually have many skills
underneath of them and so when we say
hire for attitude it really means you
know there's probably 20 different
examples of what kindness looks like
within the setting of a workplace and if
someone has zero of them that's 20
skills I have to teach them whereas if
they only need to learn how to call
leads and work leads and say a script
that might only be two to three weeks of
training but training someone to be kind
certainly takes longer than two to three
weeks
now where this flips is that there is
some point in the future where if you
have a very Niche expertise that's very
very hard to find it might be easier to
teach you to be kind than to teach you
how to code like a level 10 expert or to
be a transactional CFO that's done you
know 50 transactions before for your
type of Industry there might not be that
many people who've done that and so it
might be easier to teach them how to
behave within your culture than it is to
teach them that skill set and so this is
more true the lower level the role that
you're hiring for and less true as you
get higher but the fundamental universal
truth is that you always hire for the
small skill deficiency so the next is
that compensation attracts great
salespeople but it does not retain them
or get them to behave the way you want
to so
compensation equals
recruiting compensation in my experience
does not equal uh performance and I'm
now you might be like of course it does
I'm just telling you uh in my experience
I have never had a compensation change
really change the behavior of the team
except for one thing uh which I will
share with you if you compensate them
off of cash collected you will in
general get more cash collected but
everything else in terms of like we're
going to pay this for that and this for
that most of the times the reward cycle
is so delayed they're just going to
still just try as hard as they can to
sell and so the things that change
Behavior are typically much faster uh
and lower intensity meaning you were
addicted to your phone not because it
pays you but because it has a very fast
feedback loop and so the reason that in
general sales in Slack are
overrepresented from sales that actually
get processed is because people get
rewarded for saying I closed the deal in
slack and so they say they close deals
more times than they do and so you by
the way Pro tip on that is just create a
zap between your uh CRM and a process
sale that's been submitted and make that
the thing that goes into slack that they
get kudos on just a side little little
tip ski there for you um but it's been
my experience that you absolutely get
better closers with higher comp but and
when I say better closers I mean people
who have smaller skill deficiencies that
you need to train but then after that
trying to like redo compensation over
and over again it's very rare in my
experience that it has has changed the
behavior of the team that in a way that
training and fast feedback loops can't
do better the next is that sales and
marketing are one Continuum all right so
people see them as different departments
and for me I've actually profited a lot
um by putting them Under One Roof so I
always have our meetings as basically
Revenue generation uh and you can have a
chief Revenue officer who really
oversees acquisition overall and
since I've done this and I've done this
for years um there's basically been no
conflict between sales and marketing
they're working together to close as
many deals as possible so if you ever
have conflict where like sales is like
marketing they G they're not giving us
enough leads or the leads are and
then s uh and then marketing's telling
sales like why don't you close anything
like you should be closing right like
it's because they're sitting on opposite
side of the table but when they're
collaborating under the same roof
especially if there's one leader ahead
of it all of that disappears like I
can't remember the last time that like
Marketing sales had any kind of like
weird weirdness in companies that I own
uh and so you have you do that by
unifying them and I explain it like this
which is that they sit on one Continuum
and so fundamentally you just have a
certain amount of information that's
required to get someone to buy and so in
a hypothetical world if someone was
perfectly knowledgeable they could make
the buying decision on their own and
companies have proven that like carvana
that doesn't have salespeople or Tesla
which you can buy a car on the website
like if you have enough marketing people
can get and search for enough
information that they just make a buying
decision on their own but whenever you
have sufficient marketing to get people
to start buying on their own there's
typically an even larger pool of people
who do need more selling to occur to
close this Gap to get them to buy and so
sales think about sales as personalized
marketing which is okay you uh let's say
that there's uh one two three four uh
five six things that someone needs to
know in order to buy if marketing covers
1 two and three then you the salesperson
cover four five and six now let's say
the next Prospect comes in and they have
one three and five then you would cover
two four and six and so basically it
allows you to personalize the
information required to get this person
to make a decision I don't believe in
any kind of mysticism around like oh
over this price you have to sell over
the phone I do think that there are
behaviors in general that more people do
but I don't think it's in any way a
necessity but a lot of times there are
opportunities because there's just more
people who don't know as much as people
who buy so having a sales team will
almost always improve the overall Roi or
roaz uh asend for any kind of
acquisition process another good thing
to understand from a mindset perspective
is the difference between uh like belief
and Trust not really the difference but
belief and Trust actually exist because
people talk about like oh you need to
have trust from the prospect it's not
they have to trust you because they are
actually continuums it's how much do
they trust you how much do they believe
you and so when you think about it this
way then it's not this binary of like oh
they didn't trust you it's they didn't
trust you enough which then allows us to
have these little check marks along the
way that we can say these things
increase the belief of the prospect
these things increase the trust of the
prospect these things decrease the trust
of the Prospect and the more things you
do that get them to believe you and
trust you the more likely it is that
they will buy and so fundamentally
seeing sales in these two frames allows
you to think of sales as an education
process which you then teach them in
order to change their behavior and so
one of my one of my little isms that I
like to think of is that in general the
trust and belief that is required to
make a big purchase is smaller than the
make a little purchase and so basically
the bigger the plane so if I have a
little plane right that's a bad plane
there we go if I have a little plane
then I don't need a very long Runway to
get this plane to take off if I have a
big
plane then I'm going to need a very long
takeoff to get this to go up and so if
you're selling a more expensive thing
think about it like it's a bigger plane
which means you're going to have more
selling more information that's going to
have to happen before they make a
purchasing decision and so if you're
getting a lot of two three four call
closes it's usually because you're not
doing enough education prior to the
first call so the thing that change is
you need to create more education
materials basically you need to
pre-market them more you need to warm
them up which is just move them along
this Continuum here you need to move
them along the Continuum more so your
sales don't have to take three four five
calls but instead they get them to the 6
inch Putt and they can putt them in they
get them to the 5 yard line and they can
knock it forward the next one is what
I'll call say less and so this is uh
something that one of one of uh our
sales guys said that I said to them
apparently um and and really help them
out a lot in terms of changing their
behavior and so if you tend to be more
talkative in terms of talk time you want
to have roughly two-thirds of the talk
time from the prospect not you now gong
uh and some of these other sales tools
have released different like ideal
closing amounts but in general most
closers talk less than the Prospect and
so that's because they're asking they're
answering your questions you're not
answering theirs ideally and so one of
the things that I noticed with the most
compelling conversations uh that I've
had and the podcast that I've been on is
the m Master interviewers uh so uh
Steven Bartlett when I was on Dio and
Williamson the few times have been on on
his pod they're very good at letting
silence
sit and people like to talk about
themselves and people will expound on
themselves if you do not respond so I
would encourage you to try this so
remember I'm changing this in terms of
what does it change about Behavior if
someone says something instead of
immediately jabbing back sometimes just
let them talk more just give them more
time to talk because the more they talk
the more Rapport you have because people
like talking about themselves so they'll
think that you're amazing without you
ever saying anything all right the next
one is a story that I got told to me by
a Serial CEO seial private Equity CEO so
when I was uh when I was interviewing
CEOs of the companies that um had been
sold or been acquired by the private
Equity firms that we were we were
recording at the time they introduced me
some CEOs and actually was one of the
most valuable things I got uh from the
whole process outside of the the
transaction so one of these guys he's
from Long Island
and I'll do my very best to butcher his
accent um but I was like so what's the
secret you know for you and he said
don't be cute and I was like what do you
mean by that he's like he's like a lot
of CEOs try and get cute he's like they
uh you know it's like backyard football
you've got you know you got this super
secret double reverse fake you know
thing and then you try and do it and
what happens he's like you fumble the
ball you lose 50 yards it's a complete
waste of time he's like but what what
plays always work he's like two fat guys
in the middle run to the right right
he's like don't be cute and so I I
actually took that to heart a lot which
is basically like growing a business is
a lot like backyard football and getting
good at sales is a lot like backyard
football the best
salespeople say the script they follow
up quickly they keep Rapport they ask
good questions they listen and they
allow the prospect to close themselves
so the thing that separates the good
sales people from the great people the
great salesp people is that the great
salespeople never don't do the basics
they always do the fundamentals and when
you always do the fundamentals you will
sustain exceptionally High close rates
they always prepare for each sales call
they always do the warm handoffs they
always refer to the notes rather than
asking the customer to recap they always
set the agenda with proof promise plan
they always do those things and that's
what allows them and then when they get
asked what do you do they're like I just
do the fundamentals man it's just that
doing the fundamentals is doing a lot of
things over and over and over again and
never forgetting any of the steps and so
that's what creates Mastery that's an
exhibition of skill so the next one is
that no isn't no forever no for Now does
not equal no
forever and so the big thing is think
about it this way let's say uh you were
in the dating pool and you've got this
girl or this guy that you've got your
eye on if they say hey I can't hang out
with you I'm predisposed I have whatever
and then let's say 6 months later there
they're single that no for now doesn't
mean you should never reach out to them
again it just might mean that right now
is not the perfect time because some of
the obstacles they gave you might be
legitimate they might have another
opportunity that is higher return than
whatever you're offering they might be
going through a merger and their team is
too spread thin and it's not worth the
resources to bring on more people to do
your implementation it's very possible
that now might not be a good time but it
doesn't mean that it's a no forever and
so I say this as like okay what's the
behavior that you're going to change as
a result of this is that you should not
be ashamed of reaching out every 3 to
six months just for a pulse check this
is where sending those fun memes or
those on line emails can make you so
much money because so many sales people
are afraid to follow up one because it's
work and two because they're afraid of
rejection but if you're not afraid of
work and you're not afraid of rejection
because you believe genuinely which you
should that you're going to help this
Prospect because they are qualified for
whatever the solution is then just
circle up when they have a better time
all right the next one is be a trash man
all right and so this is especially for
the younger closers uh that are you know
just getting into this um and so I'll
give you another one underneath of that
which is yellow equals gold
so in companies that we have we like to
do something called lead scoring which
is basically putting an approximation on
How likely it is that this lead closes
so earlier I told you the story of the
salesman who was uh you know selling
time shares became the number one guy
and the way that he was able to become
that super super duper closer was
because they began scoring leads so we
could say this guy who's got an 800
credit score and makes $500,000 a year
is more likely to buy a time share than
this person who's got you know six jobs
and 19 Kids and is on welfare and
whatever right like the likelihood is
it's higher that this person's going to
close so that person will get a higher
lead score and so what happens is
oftentimes you have a score Andor a
color that's associated with that so
you've got like greens yellows and reds
and so a red would be a just unqualified
yellows are like slightly qualified but
like probably a lower quality lead and
so if you're new salesperson you want to
be a trashman you want to be willing to
take as many calls as the company will
let you take and so think about this way
you are going to get free training from
the hardest leads which are the best
training grounds for you to learn how to
sell and so you need to think of those
yellows as Golds it's a reframe and so I
remember thinking about this when I was
selling in person that I had like some
homeless people who'd respond to my ads
and so they'd come in and i' you know I
had people just getting out of jail you
know after a 10e stint you know 30 days
earlier coming in like no job whatever
like I dealt with everything that came
in through the door and I thought about
it and I was like this is such a waste
of my time but I was like what if this
were amazing how could this be an
amazing thing for me and I was like well
man if I can close a homeless person if
I can close somebody who has no money no
job that would mean that I've gotten
really good at the skill and so I just
saw this is advanced level bosses that I
got to go against rather than this is a
waste of my time and so if you're
younger in the sales or and you're not
getting as many reps with the green
leads then ask for all the trash leads
because there's usually more than a
company can possibly handle in
unqualified now again if someone
literally cannot benefit from the
product don't sell it but if it's they
are less qualified as in like they have
less Financial Resources things like
that then you can still practice closing
and so think about it and we say this
term sharpen the sword is that you want
to just keep sharpening your skill
sharpening the axe taking more wax at
the tree and repetition is the mother of
skill and repeating yourself when it's a
hard Prospect to close just makes the
easier ones that much easier so this
next one sounds similar to things I've
said in the past but it's different so
objections do not mean no all
right so let me explain what I mean by
that so on one level obviously you can
overcome an objection with whatever
you're going to handle but a lot of
times they just are voicing out loud
their reaction this is especially true
when it comes to prices so if someone
says wow that's expensive it doesn't
mean automatically that you need to
start overcoming price objections you
could say yeah
totally it doesn't like there have
probably many times in your life when
you've been like oh that's expensive and
then you still bought it you just it was
expensive it was more than you expected
but it doesn't mean that you're not
going to buy and so a lot of times
people just say things as they come out
but it doesn't mean you're not buying
and so an experienced salesperson is
going to trying to start overcoming
things and you're basically like Wasting
Bullets on on on zombies that aren't
there they were going to close either
way that's not a real objection they
haven't said no they just made an
observation so unless someone says they
don't want to buy don't assume that they
don't want to buy next one is we don't
negotiate with terrorists which is never
change
price to close a
sale now the reason this is so important
is obviously one because people talk and
then customers won't like if you're
changing a sale price between different
customers now testing price absolutely
you should test your prices but that
should be done ahead of time
premeditated saying these next time
we're going to try this out and see what
happens not oh I got to close this guy
so I'm going to lower the price to do it
all right and so my favorite overcome
for hey can I do it can you guys do it
for Less is we could do it for more and
as silly as that sounds that has never
not worked for me and I'm still like I
have like a perfect batting average on
that one and so the thing is is that
it's such a high indication of
purchasing intention when someone says
can you do it for $500 less can you do
it for 30 grand instead of 50 Grand
whatever that just saying we could do it
for more what it does is it actually re
anchors so if you're familiar with
anchoring so let's say you say price is
this they say well I want to pay 20% off
that you then say cool well I'm going to
say plus 20% and so basically it re
anchors above it counter anchors and
then they have a fear of missing out
because all of a sudden the one price
now becomes even more and they're like
no no no no and a lot of times they just
say no no I'm good I'll buy I'm I'm fine
I'm fine and so uh never change price to
close a deal now you can change terms so
if you want to change how much they pay
today then you have a payment plan if
you want to change the uh components of
the offer then you have a feature
downsell those are very very different
than discounts that you give for no
reason and so you never negotiate with
terrorists because if they see you
change your price for them once they'll
believe that every price you have is
negotiable and then they'll tell
everyone it is too so the next one that
we'll cover is the idea that people want
to buy so think about this when you are
perusing on a site you want the thing
people usually want the stuff people
like buying the only reason that they
don't buy is because they have a history
of being punished for buying in the past
but they want to buy and so our job as
sales professionals or entrepreneurs is
to help them justify making the decision
and so people want an excuse to buy you
need to give it to them and so earlier I
said closers ask hard questions but my
team hit this hit this pretty hard for
me uh in terms of it being a big one so
I'm GNA I'm going to highlight it with a
little bit more detail so the reason
closers ask hard questions uh is because
they genuinely
care and the reason that's so important
is that you want to be kind not nice
because nice guys don't want to offend
someone kind people want to genuinely
help and if you want to genuinely help
then you want them to change their
behavior just like these things
hopefully change your behavior in terms
of selling and so that means that you
sometimes have to call them on their BS
and the tactful way to doing that is
that you want to confront those hard
questions one before you've asked for
money and two through foils of other
people like them this is what allows you
to stay in the pocket in the sale and
continue to ask the questions that
genuinely can change this person's life
and if you always come from the
perspective of human first you will
usually maintain Rapport if you don't
then what you will get is something we
call commission breath which is it
sounds like you're not listening to them
and you are prioritizing the closeth
over the person and that's where you
lose them completely because now they
feel like your incentives are no longer
aligned if you come at it from I want
the best thing for you then you will
always be on their side of the table
your incentives as far as they're
concerned will always always be aligned
with theirs and you will be able to ask
the questions that are actually going to
change their lives all right so those
are the behaviors that you can change as
a salesperson to make more sales